AND WELCOME TO OUR ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY FOR
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
LEGISLATIVE SESSION I AM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES.
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE I
WOULD BE THIS MORNING WE HAVE
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
JOBS COMMITTEE INCLUDING OUR
VICE CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM.
AS WELL AS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR WITH THIS TODAY.
ALSO JOINING US ARE THE
LEGISLATIVE POLICY STAFF.
INCLUDING TOURNEY SIMON'S ARCHIE
CONSULTANTS WITH THE ASSEMBLY
JOBS COMMITTEE BENNETT WAR
HEIGHTS ARE COMMITTEE SECRETARY
WITH THE ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE
AND CAITLIN COOK WITH THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS POLICY
CONSULTANT.
MISTER SECRETARY I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A QUORUM IF YOU CAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
REMAIN HERE [inaudible]
JOHN YEAH [inaudible]
GEN [inaudible]
THREE OF US [inaudible]
YEAH.
OUR FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
CHIU.
THE COMMITTEE RULES.
MEMBERS A COPY OF THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE ROLES IS IN YOUR
BINDER UNDER TAB.
FOR THERE ARE ALSO COPIES FOR
THE PUBLIC ON THE OUTSIDE PUBLIC
DOCUMENTATION ALL DO I HAVE A
MOTION ON THE COMMITTEE ROLES.
THANK YOU.
I BELIEVE MR CHOW --
MOTIONED AND OR VICE CHAIR
MISTER COMING CUNNINGHAM
SECONDED THE MOTION THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE RULES BE ADOPTED.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS.
DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH.
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THE COMMITTEE
ROLES.
SEE.
NINE I WILL RESTATE THE MOTION
**** SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE MOTION THE
MOTION IS ADOPT THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE ROLES.
BUT WHEN HIS PROPOSED COMMITTEE
RULES THE MOTION IS ADOPT THE
PROPOSED CAN BE RULES.
TEARS AROUND AS CHAIR CERVANTES
AYE FASTER CUNNINGHAM.
POSTER CUNNINGHAM HI CHAU
[inaudible]
CHAU ONLY.
RAMOS ON A REVERSE.
RIVERS ON A SMITH [inaudible]
SMITH HI.
MEMBERS OF BOTH CURRENTLY STANDS
AT SIX ZERO THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED.
THE RULES ARE ADOPTED EXCUSE ME.
WHAT NOW THAT WE?
ADOPTED THE COMMITTEE ROLES I
LIKE TO START OFF WITH A FEW
OPENING REMARKS BEFORE WE INVITE
THE FIRST PANEL AT I TODAY'S
HEARING IS A SECOND IN A SERIES
OF HEARINGS SPONSORED BY THE
ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE.
AND WHICH WE ARE EXAMINING
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AN INCLUSIVE --
ECONOMIC GROWTH IN THE FIRST
HEARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE
BRIEFED ON KEY ELEMENTS OF THE
STATE ECONOMY INCLUDING
SIGNIFICANT INDUSTRY SECTORS
ECONOMIC TRENDS AND STAKEHOLDER
INITIATIVES.
AND GOALS FOR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WELL WE HEARD TESTIMONY
ON THE STATE'S MANY ECONOMIC
SUCCESSES WE ALSO DISCUSSED THE
INCREASED INCOME AN OPPORTUNITY
GAP WHICH IS RESULTING IN
CERTAIN AREAS OF THE STATE.
AND POPULATION GROUPS FAILING
AND FOUGHT FURTHER AND FURTHER
BEHIND.
THE SECOND HEARING BILLS ON MANY
OF THE SAME THEMES AND WE DIG A
LITTLE DEEPER INTO STRATEGIES TO
SUPPORT UPWARD MOBILITY AN
INDEPENDENT ECONOMIC SECURITY.
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF THE
STATE'S OTHER RESPONSIBILITIES.
JUST AS INCOME INEQUALITY IS
FORTY COMMUNITIES ARE ALSO BEING
CHALLENGED TO BECOME MORE
RESILIENT AND AN INCREASINGLY
HOSTILE ENVIRONMENT AND
RESULTING FROM CLIMATE CHANGE
ANOTHER COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
ISSUES. TO HELP GET THIS ISSUE
ODD STARTED TODAY WE HAVE
ORGANIZED A HEARING INTO THREE
PARTS.
FIRST AN OVERVIEW OF INCOME
INEQUALITY AND A POTENTIAL
FRAMEWORK FOR REDUCING SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC DISPARITIES AMONG
CALIFORNIANS SEC IT WE WILL MOVE
FROM POLICY TO PRACTICE.
AND HEAR ABOUT HOW OUR COMMUNITY
IS USING STATE CLIMATE CHANGE
AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS
TO SUPPORT THE NEIGHBORHOOD
REVITALIZATION.
AND THIRD IT WE WILL HEAR FROM
SEVERAL CALIFORNIA'S LARGER
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT RELATED
PROGRAMS ON HOW WE ARE USING
EXISTING PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
WITH THE STATE ALREADY INVESTING
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND CLIMATE MITIGATION THE
ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE WILL BE
LEARNING MORE ABOUT THESE ISSUES
ON INVESTMENT IN HOW WE ARE THE
IMPORTANCE OF OPPORTUNITIES TO
DELIVER TRIPLE BOTTLE WALK.
BOTTOM LINE OUTCOME FOR
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES ACROSS OUR STATE.
SO BEFORE WE BEGIN I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK -- BY
SURE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE A
FEW OPENING COMMENTS.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT SEE NINE I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE OUR FIRST SPEAKER --
WITH US TODAY. TO JOIN US TWENTY
MIN DHAKA.
AND JUST FOR THE PUBLIC I LIKE
BACKGROUND REPORT PREPARED BY
THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
AMONG OTHER INFORMATION YOU WILL
FIND AN OVERVIEW OF THE STATE
ECONOMY AND INCREASING.
CHALLENGE INCOME INEQUALITY IS
HAVING ON CALIFORNIA SHORT
PROFILES OF THE STATE AGENCIES
ARE WHO ARE GOING TO BE
PRESENTING TODAY AND SOME
SPECIAL APPENDICES ON SMALL
BUSINESSES AND RELATED
LEGISLATION AND BUDGET ITEMS --
ALLOW ME TO INTRODUCE OUR FIRST
SPEAKER --
WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY AND VICE CHAIR OF
THE INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS AND
TRADE DEVELOPMENT INTER AGENCY
COMMITTEE?
SHERMAN DOCTOR COMES TO THIS BE
JUDY'S WITH THE UNIQUE PART
PRIVATE SECTOR BACKGROUND
INCLUDING HAVING SERVED.
AS SERVED AT THE SENIOR PARTNER
WITH MACKENZIE AND COMPANY AND A
LECTURER ON INEQUALITY AT THE
STANFORD BUSINESS SCHOOL --
WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU OKAY.
GREAT THANK YOU CHAIRWOMAN
CERVANTES AND THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME HERE TO JOIN YOU
TODAY IT'S A GREAT PLEASURE TO
BE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU ALL.
IT'S ALSO NICE TO BE HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH THIS COMMITTEE
BECAUSE I REMEMBER POSTING THE
COMMITTEE IN --
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC
SUMMIT IN THE INLAND EMPIRE A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO AND SO IT'S
A GREAT PLEASURE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH YOU
TODAY.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS GIVE YOU
A LITTLE BIT OF OVER VIEW ABOUT
HOW ONE THINKING ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE?
AND HOW WE MIGHT MOVE FORWARD ON
TRYING TO ENSURE AS YOU'RE.
HEARING HAS DESCRIBED HELPING
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE AN INCLUSIVE
ECONOMY THAT WORKS FOR EVERYONE --
YOU MAY NOT KNOW FROM MY BIO BUT
I WAS BORN IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA --
I AT GREW UP ON A DAIRY FARM MY
FAMILY STILL HAS THAT FORM THERE.
AND I HAVE THE PART OF THE
REASON THAT I WAS ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT TAKING THIS JOB.
IS TO HELP ENSURE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY WORKS FOR
EVERYONE.
AND NOT JUST THOSE WHO HAPPEN TO
BE IN PLACE --
BENEFIT FROM THEIR HEAD TAIL
WINDS THAT ARE MOVING THE
ECONOMY FORWARD AND THAT'S A
LARGE PART OF WHAT I TEACH AT
STANFORD BUSINESS SCHOOL IS
THINKING ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES
TO BUILD A MORE INCLUSIVE
ECONOMY IN WAYS THAT WORK FOR
BUSINESS AND WORK FOR THE
ECONOMY.
SO I'M EXCITED TO TAK THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
AND THERE IS.
A REAL OPPORTUNITY I BELIEVE TO
ENSURE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY ACTUALLY HAS SUSTAINABLE
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
THAT WORKS FOR ALL CITIZENS.
ENSURING THAT IT IS AN ECONOMY
THAT IS BOTH RESILIENT THROUGH
THIS ECONOMIC CYCLES.
THAT IS ONE WHICH CREATES JOBS.
NOT JUST IN THE PART OF THE
ECONOMY AND IN THIS PARTY
ECONOMIC CYCLE THAT IS AT THE
TOP OF THE CYCLE. ONE THAT
INSURERS THAT WE ARE DOING THAT
IN WAYS WHICH IS GOOD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND ONE THAT HELPS CREATE HIGH
QUALITY JOBS FOR CITIZENS AND SO
I THINK ABOUT MY ROLE AS THE
CHIEF ECONOMIC AND BUSINESS
ADVISER THE GOVERNOR AS WELL AS
THE ROLE IN THE GOVERNMENT'S
OFFICE OF ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
TO ENSURE THAT THAT HAPPENS
TRYING TO HELP MAKE THAT HAPPEN
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT ARE BEYOND OUR
CONTROL AND THINGS ARE NOT
WITHIN.
THE PURVIEW OF WHAT THAT
SPECIFIC THAT'S WHAT I'M WHERE
I'M COMING FROM.
I DID A WEAPON ARE HOT WITH --
CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC SUMMIT THAT
PRESENTED A LOT OF THE DETAIL
AND CERTAINLY IF ANYONE WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE ACCESS TO THAT IT'S
ON THE WEBSITE.
ON OUR WEBSITE --
LET ME TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
FIVE THINGS THAT ARE THINK ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THESE
OPPORTUNITIES.
THE FIRST ONE IS THAT.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
ARE HINKING ABOUT HOW REGION'S
RISE TOGETHER.
AB THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HELP ENSURE THE ECONOMY WORKS
BUT IT'S DIFFERENT CONTEXTS AND
WHAT PART OF THE STATE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND SO THE WAY I
THINK ABOUT THAT IS NOT THAT WE
NEED ONE TOP DOWN STATE APPROACH.
BUT THE WE NEED TO HELP INSURE
THAT WHAT'S NECESSARY FOR
ECONOMIC SUCCESS IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE IN THE CENTRAL PART OF
THE STATE IN THE THE FAR EAST
AND THE FAR NORTH OR DRIVEN BY
WHAT THOSE REGIONS BELIEVE IS
IMPORTANT AND THAT THE STATE'S
ROLE WAS TO HELP AND HAVE.
ENABLE THEIR SUCCESS SO IT'S
ABOUT REGION'S RISING AND RISING
BOTH FOR WHAT THEY NEED AND WELL
AS CONNECTING THEM SO THAT THERE
ARE COMPLEMENTARY CAPABILITIES
OF DIFFERENT REGIONS THAT THEY
CAN WORK TOGETHER.
THE SECOND THING IS THAT THERE
IS AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF THIS
WHICH IS REALLY ABOUT ENSURING
THAT THE HEARTLAND OF THE
STATE'S SUCCEEDS.
AND BY THAT I MEAN THE PARTS OF
THE STATE THAT HAVE HAD LESS
ATTENTION.
FROM POLICY HISTORICALLY FROM
THE MEDIA AND LESS FRANKLY FOCUS
ON HOW WE SUPPORT WHAT'S
NECESSARY FOR SUCCESS IN THE
HEARTLAND OF THE STATE.
THAT'S NOT AT THE THAT THAT THAT
NOT LOOKING UP OF THE COAST BUT
REALLY ENSURING THAT THERE IS A
FOCUS.
ON CENTRA CALIFORNIA THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND PARTS WHERE THAT THE
EFFORT CAN HELP ENSURE THAT THAT
WHAT'S NECESSARY THERE TO
SUCCEED WE SUPPORT.
THE THIRD THING THAT I THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND YOU SAW
SOME OF THIS ANNOUNCEMENT LAST
WEEK.
IS THAT CALIFORNIA IS A GLOBALLY
CONNECTED ECONOMY.
WE NEED TO ENSURE.
THAT THE EXPORT OPPORTUNITIES
THAT ARE AT FRONT AND CENTER FOR
MANY OF OUR BUSINESSES AND THE
STATE HAVE REAL ATTENTION.
AND AT THE CAPITOL AN INTEREST
THAT IS AVAILABLE OUTSIDE THIS
COUNTRY TO BE ABLE TO INVEST IN
JOB CREATING OPPORTUNITIES IN
OUR STATE.
IS MADE AVAILABLE AND SO YOU SAW
LAST WEEK PROBABLY AT THE
GOVERNOR STOOD UP THE COMMISSION
THE INTERAGENCY COMMISSION THAT
YOU MENTION AS WELL AS APPOINTED.
HAD NAME THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
AS THE IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE THE
STATE TO HELP FACE --
THE OPPORTUNITIES TO REPRESENT
THE STATE AROUND THE WORLD --
IN MY ROLE AS IN THE SURE THAT
WE HAVE [inaudible]
REAL FOR APPROACH TO HAVE
CALIFORNIA FACE THE EXTERNAL
WORLD I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE I'M SURE YOU WILL HEAR
FROM YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
THAT CONCERNS ABOUT.
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO EXPORT
IS HURTING OUR JOB CREATION SO
TRYING TO HELP ENSURE THAT WE'VE
GOT A FOCUS ON INTERNATIONAL.
THE FOURTH THING I'D LIKE TO SAY
IS THAT --
THERE IS AN IMPORTANT IT I KNOW
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS LATER
TODAY TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT THAT WE
NEED.
SO WE HAVE AN AN AMAZINGLY
VIBRANT ECONOMY OVERALL.
AND WE HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ARE REALLY TRYING TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT ECONOMY.
AND ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE ALL
OF THE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO HAVE
THE SKILLS THAT THEY NEED AND
THE ADVANCEMENT OPPORTUNITIES
SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT FROM A FROM
THE ECONOMY STANDPOINTS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT WHEN I'M
TALKING TO BUSINESS LEADERS
ACROSS THE STATE THAT'S ONE OF
THE FIRST THINGS THEY SAY TO ME.
AND IT'S IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO WE HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO COULD USE SOME HELP
IN ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE.
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT THAT
THEY NEED.
AND FINALLY THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP DEPLOY
CAPITAL IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE STATE AND FOR THINGS THAT
ARE HIGH PRIORITIES.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET MASH
MENTIONED OPPORTUNITIES OWNS WE
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT UP
TOOL IN A SET OF TOOL KITS TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE DELIVERING.
THE CAPITAL OPPORTUNITIES THAT
ARE IF THAT IS COMBINED WITH A
WHOLE SET OF OTHER TOOLS IN THE
TOOL KIT OF ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
INCLUDING.
ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS.
AND OTHER ELEMENTS THAT THE THE
STATE HAS EXISTING PROGRAMS TO
HELP ALIGN THOSE AROUND ENSURING
THAT THAT CAP WAS DEPLOYED FOR
JOB CREATION.
AND JOB CREATION THAT HELPS WITH
OTHER GOALS LIKE CARBON
REDUCTION AND HIGH QUALITY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
SO WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL.
OF ALL OF THIS IS IN THE CONTEXT
OF WHAT I THINK OF AS TO WHAT IS
BOTH SMART POLICY.
AND SMART INVESTMENT.
CAPITAL PROVIDERS AND BUSINESS
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN BUSINESS FOR
THE LONG TERM THINK ABOUT THEIR
ROLE AND SHOULD THINK ABOUT THE
ROLE IS HELPING MAKE THE ECONOMY
WORK NOT JUST THEIR NARAL SHORT
TERM PROFIT INTERESTS.
AND WHERE IT WHEN WE'RE AT OUR
BEST THAT'S WHAT POLICY HELPS
ENABLE HELPS ENABLE HIGH QUALITY
BUSINESSES WHO ARE JOB CREATORS.
GOOD FOR THE ENVIRONMENT AND OUR
HELP IN ADVANCE THE SET OF
POLICY OBJECTIVESDO THE RIGHT
THING THEY LIKE TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND OUR JOB IS TO HELP
SUPPORT THEM AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THE POSSIBILITY AS THIS IS
ALL IN THE CONTEXT.
OF HOW DO WE HELP ENSURE THE
COUNTY CALIFORNIA ECONOMY WORKS
FOR EVERYONE AND THAT WE CAN
RENEW THE CALIFORNIA DREAM THAT
MANY OF US INCLUDING ME CAME TO
THE STATE IN THE FIRST PLACE I
WOULD.
I WAS BORN HERE BUT MY PARENTS
WERE MIGRANTS.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ALL --
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS OR
TAKE PERSPECTIVES ON WHAT THE
WHAT YOU.
WOULD LIKE TO AND APPRECIATE THE
TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I WOULD LIKE
TO OPEN IT UP TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS AT
THIS MOMENT.
MR ALMOST JUST --
ONE CHAIR WHEN YOU SAY REGIS AND
AND RISING TOGETHER BUT THEIR
SPECIFIC NEEDS IN EACH ONE OF
THOSE REGIONS THAT NEEDS TO BE
IDENTIFIED.
AND YOU TALK ABOUT THE INLAND
EMPIRE IN THOSE AREAS SO CAN YOU
ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT MORE AND
SOME OF THOSE ARE.
SURE SO --
THE BUT IF WE WERE SET UP IS
SEPARATE STATES WITHIN AN
ECONOMY WE HAVE THE RICHEST
STATE IN THE COUNTRY AND SILICON
VALLEY AND WE HAVE THE POOREST
STATE IN THE COUNTRY IN THE
CENTER PART OF THE STATE FROM
CENTRAL VALLEY TO THE INLAND
EMPIRE.
AND THAT'S EVEN FOR THE COST OF
DEFINITELY WOULD HAVE A WIDE
DISPERSION OF INCOME AND SO WHAT
WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT IS
THE CENTER PART OF THE STATE.
SO CENTRAL CALIFORNIA THE INLAND
EMPIRE AS A FIRST PRIORITY
THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF THE THE
GROWTH IS IT'S A LOT OF WEAR
THAT THE POPULATION GROWTH IS
IT'S A LOT OF WHERE THE THE
ECONOMIC NEEDS ARE IT'S A LOT OF
WHERE.
THE FUTURE OF THE WORK FORCE IS
COMING FROM AND FRANKLY IT'S A
PLACE WHERE WE NOT PAID AS MUCH
ATTENTION AS A STATE AND I THINK
THERE'S A REAL OPPORTUNITY.
TO ENSURE THAT WHAT INLAND
EMPIRE NEEDS.
WE HELP.
AND WHAT CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
NEEDS WE HELP IT'S NOT THAT WE
HAVE THE ANSWERS IT'S HELP AND
WORK WITH THEM. TO HELP
UNDERSTAND THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS
AND THEN WORK WITH THEM TO HELP
ENABLE THAT [inaudible]
THE CHAPEL.
YOU MENTION ABOUT EXPERT --
AND I'M JUST WONDERING OF WHAT
DE IMPACTS HAVE BEEN UP WITH THE
MOST RECENT TRADE WAR ARE AND
HOW IT HAS IMPACTED --
VERY SECTORS ARE WHO ARE
CONDUCTING BUSINESSES HERE IN
THE STATES OR IN AND A IN
EXPORTING FOR EXAMPLE AND HOW
BOB DAVIE COULD COPE WITH THE
SITUATION.
NOW AND INTO THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER TRY
THAT THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION --
THE OF THE US IS TRYING TO GET A
BETTER HANDLE ON THAT IN TERMS
OF ECONOMIC STATISTICS IN THE
STATE IS AS WELL --
SO WE DON'T HAVE A COMPLETE VIEW
OF IT IN A YOU KNOW.
COMPREHENSIVE WHAT WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS THE INDICATIONS ARE AND
CERTAINLY THE ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE
WHEN I'M OUT ACROSS THE STATE
AND I'M SURE YOU'RE HEARING IT
AS WELL IS EXTREMELY NEGATIVE.
IT IS A TERRACE HAVE HELPED
CREATE A BARRIER TO HIGH QUALITY
BUSINESSES WHO WANT TO EXPORT.
BECAUSE IT'S PREVENTED THEM IN
TERMS OF THEIR ABILITY HAVE
ACCESS TO OTHER MARKETS AND IT'S
ALSO RAISE THEIR COSTS. FOR
IMPORTS THAT THEY HAVE COMING IN
TO TRY AND HELP THEIR BUSINESS
SUCCEED --
ALMOST EVERY ECHO ARE A BAD
ECONOMIC TOOL.
AND SO TRYING TO GET A HANDLE ON
EXACTLY THE IMPACT OF THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU ARE TAKING A
LOOK AT MY PERSONAL BELIEF IS
THAT IT IS.
UP THE EVEN MORE NEGATIVE FOR
CALIFORNIA THAN IT IS FOR MOST
OF THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE WE ARE MUCH MORE
EXPLORATORIUM ALMOST BY
DEFINITION IT'S GOING TO BE
WORSE.
AND SECONDLY IT IS WHEN WE GET
INTO WORD AFFECTS PARTICULAR
INDUSTRIES AND PARTICULAR DROP
GEOGRAPHIES IT'S UNFORTUNATELY
MOST LIKELY TO HURT THOSE THAT
CAN LEAST AFFORD FOR IT TO BE
HEARD.
SO SMALL MANUFACTURERS WHO RELY
ON INTERNATIONAL EXPECTS PORTS
AND FOR THEIR PRODUCTS TO COME
IN AGRICULTURE WHO ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY EPENDENT ON THE
STATE ON EXPORTS.
THOSE WHO ARE IMPORTING PRODUCTS
FROM OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD TO
ADD VALUE TO THEM IN CALIFORNIA
OR HURT WHEN THOSE INPUT COSTS
COME UP BECAUSE THEY CAN'T PASS
THAT ON TO TWO OTHERS VERY
EASILY.
AND THEN THOSE WERE BUYING THOSE
ARE HURT TOO SO IT IS A HORRIBLE
ECONOMIC POLICY AND TRYING TO
THINK ABOUT HOW CALIFORNIA.
CAN STE ARTICULATE WHY WE NEED
TO HAVE A PRODUCTIVE GLOBAL
RELATIONSHIP IS KIND OF WHERE
WE'RE I THINK WE OUGHT TO BE HAD.
TO ADD ON TO THAT WERE ARE SOME
OPPORTUNITIES WERE CALIFORNIA
CAN ENHANCE OUR GLOBAL
COMPETITIVE NEST WITHIN THIS
LARGER MARKET THANK YOU AB.
SO WE ARE VERY EARLY IN THE
PROCESS OF DEVELOPING THAT FULL
AND COMPLETE STRATEGY --
THE ONE WAY TO THINK ABOUT IT IS
WHERE ARE THE EXISTING LARGE
TRADING PARTNERS OF THE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO THOSE WOULD BE --
PLACES THE OF THEIR GEOGRAPHIC
LOCATION CERTAINLY TO THE SOUTH
MEXICO AND CENTRAL AMERICA TO
THE NORTH CANADA.
CHINA SOUTHEAST ASIA MORE
BROADLY WE HAVE AN IMPORTANT
RELATIONSHIP WITH INDIA SO IT'S
IT'S THE ECONOMY IS WHERE WE
HAVE EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS AND
POTENTIAL FOR LARGER INTERACTION.
IT'S ALSO AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT
TO THINK ABOUT THE THE THE
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY FLOWS THE
GO BETWEEN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY SO IT'S NOT JUST
GOODS THAT MOVE ON SHIPS ACROSS
OR ON TRAINS OR ON TRUCKS ACROSS
BORDERS.
IT'S ALSO THE THE FLOWS OF
INFORMATION AND PEOPLE AND IDEAS
THAT WE NEED TO THINK HARD ABOUT.
AND THEN FINALLY I DO THINK
THERE'S AN ELEMENT OF THE
SWITCHES JUST FACING UP TO THE
REALITY OF OUR CONNECTION WITH
MANY OF OUR RESIDENTS ARE FROM
OUR FIRST GENERATION WERE SECOND
GENERATION RESIDENTS FROM OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD HAVE
IMPORTANT CONNECTIONS TO THEM.
AND SO HOW DO WE HELP INSURE
THAT THAT CONNECTION IS ENABLED
NOT DISRUPTED BY BY --
INTERNATIONAL ACTIVITY OBVIOUSLY
AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT THIS IS
FEDERAL POLICY ANDERSON AND
THAT'S NOT OUR ROLE.
BUT OUR ABILITY TO ARTICULATE
THAT HAVING A GLOBALLY RELEVANT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH CAN BE
GOOD FOR OUR CITIZENS AND OUR
BUSINESSES IS SOMETHING THAT WE
WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT TALKING
ABOUT.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY WITH THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR WHO WAS AN
AMBASSADOR AND IS REALLY REALLY
CAPABLE OF COMMUNICATING THAT TO
HELP US PLAY THAT ROLE.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU --
I WAS CURIOUS AS TO YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT WHAT'S BEEN
CALLED THE THE SKILLS GAP
MEANING THAT IT'S ESTIMATED THAT
THERE ARE GOING TO BE ABOUT FIVE
POINT FIVE MILLION --
RETIRED PEOPLE RETIRING OUT OF
THE SKILLED TRADES IN THE NEXT
FIVE TO TEN YEARS --
SOME OF US IN THIS BUILDING AND
WORKED VERY HARD TO SUPPORT
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION OUR
K. TWELVE SYSTEM AS WELL AS OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. TO TRY
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THAT TO TRAIN
THE NEXT GENERATION OF OF THE
SKILLED WORKFORCE.
AND I WAS WONDERING IF YOU HAD
ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT --
TERM THREAT THE SKILLS GAP POSES
TO OUR CONTINUED PROSPERITY.
THANK YOU OF SOME CUNNINGHAM
IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I'M I THINK OF IT AS BOTH THE
SKILLS GAP AND AN OPPORTUNITY
GAP.
SO WE HAVE.
AN ENORMOUS NUMBER OF JOB
OPENINGS THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE
AND WE HAVE A A RETIREMENT OF A
A LARGE PORTION OF THE THE
POPULATION HAS BEEN FILLING SOME
OF THOSE NEEDS.
THAT MEANS THAT THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY IN ADDITION TO A GAP
AND SO WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
HELP INSURE THAT BOTH THROUGH
OUR K. TO TWELVE SYSTEM ARE
HIGHER POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
SYSTEM AND OUR WORK FOR SYSTEM.
THAT WE ARE ENSURING THAT THE
SETS OF FOLKS WHO ARE INTERESTED
IN THOSE KINDS OF ROLES HAVE THE
SKILLS THAT THEY NEED TO BOTH
ENTER THOSE JOBS BUT ALSO
ADVANCE.
SO ON THE GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED
REALLY IMPORTANT PRIORITY AROUND
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
APPRENTICESHIPS IN THE STATE.
PART OF WHAT WILL HAPPEN WHEN
THE WORLD THE WORK CHANGES IS
THAT IT'S YOU WON'T BE.
DOING ALL OF YOUR LEARNING BY
THE TIME YOU'RE TWENTY AND AND
EARNING FOR THE REST YOUR LIFE
IT'S GOING TO BE A CONTINUOUS
PROCESS OF LEARNING AND LEARNING
THROUGHOUT.
I DON'T THINK THAT IS
FRIGHTENING THROUGHOUT THEIR
LIFE AND SO OUR ROLE IS TO HELP
THEM.
INSURED THAT WHATEVER IT IS THAT
WE HAVE THAT WE CAN HELP.
WE WANT TO HELP INSURE THAT
THEY'VE GOT THOSE SKILLS SO --
I'VE IDEA I THINK IT IS BATES
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT ISSUE
FOR DEMOGRAPHY BECAUSE OF THE
THE NATURE OF WHAT OUR WORK
FORCES IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT ISSUE
BECAUSE OF THE CHANGING NATURE
OF WORK THAT WILL BE HAPPENING
GOING FORWARD.
SO WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE THE SKILLS TO
ENTER THE SETS OF JOB
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE THERE BUT
AS WORK CHANGES OVER TIME
BECAUSE OF TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE OF
GLOBALIZATION JUST BECAUSE OF
HOW.
OCCUPATIONS AND INDUSTRIES
CHANGE THAT WE HELP THEM ENSURE
THEY HAVE THE LIFETIME SKILLS TO
BE ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE AND HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO MOVE UP THE
CAREER LADDER THROUGHOUT THEIR
LIVES [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REVERSED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
YOU KNOW I LIKE YOUR COMMENTS
ABOUT DIFFERENT APPROACHES FOR
DIFFERENT REGIONS LIKE OR AS YOU
SAY DO YOU KNOW REGION'S RISING
TOGETHER --
AND RIGHT NOW WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO TO LIGHT UP IT
ALMOST SEEMS LIKE WE COULD ALSO
HAVE A REGIONAL APPROACH FOR
THAT RIGHT WHERE --
THE BUSINESSES AND REGION ARE
WORKING WITH THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE SECTOR TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WERE LINING RIGHT THOSE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES --
FOR KIDS DO YOU HAVE ANY AYE.
GET THERE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REST THAT IS AN ESSENTIAL
ELEMENT OF WHAT'S COULD BE AS
NECESSARY FOR DIFFERENT REGIONS
TO BE ABLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL
GIVEN WHAT THE PARTICULAR NEEDS
OF THE REGION ARE.
IT'S NOT LIKE WHAT WE WANT TO
HAVE IS AN EDUCATION SYSTEM
THAT'S OVER HERE I WORK FOR
SYSTEM THAT'S OVER HERE AND
BUSINESSES THAT ARE OVER HERE.
THEY NEED TO BE AND COORDINATED
IN A WAY THAT HELPS ENSURE.
THAT THE AT THE NEEDS THAT
BUSINESS AND EMPLOYERS HAVE ARE
ALIGNED WITH WHAT THE SKILL
DEVELOPMENT THAT HAPPENS IN THE
WORKFORCE SYSTEM IN THE K. TO
TWELVE AND POST SECONDARY SYSTEM
DOES THAT'S EASIER SAID THAN
DONE -- BUT
I THINK THERE ARE REALLY SOME
INTERESTING EXAMPLES ACROSS THE
STATE OF PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING
THAT REALLY WELL --
THERE ARE EXAMPLES IN AND IN AND
OUT PLACES THAT PEOPLE AREN'T
PAYING ATTENTION TO IN TERMS OF
THEIR SUCCESS.
SO THERE ARE A WHO ARE DOING
REALLY INTERESTING THINGS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
OF HELP ENSURING THAT THERE ARE
ALIGNED THEIR CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION WITH WHAT THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE.
THERE INTERESTING PARTNERSHIPS
IN PLACES THAT ARE CREATING
PROMISE PROGRAMS FROM EARLY
CHILDHOOD ALL THE WAY THROUGH
THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL THROUGH POST
SECONDARY. TO ENSURE THAT THERE
ARE WARRANT HAVING EVERYONE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE.
IN THAT IN THE WORK FORCE GOING
FORWARD AND I THINK WHAT PART OF
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS UNDERSTAND
IN DIFFERENT REGIONS OF THE
STATE WHAT IS WORKING THERE.
WHAT CAN WE ACCELERATE WITH WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND WHAT ARE THE
THINGS THAT ARE WORKING IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE OR
HONESTLY DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY?
THAT WE CAN HELP AND TRANSFER
THOSE BEST PRACTICES SO GO IN
AND LOOK LOOK AND UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S WORKING IT'S REALLY ABOUT
ACCELERATING THOSE GREAT
SUCCESSES AND THERE ARE ALL OVER
THE STATE.
HOW DO YOU WOULD YOU SEE THE
STATE'S TRANSITION INTO A LOWER
CARBON ECONOMY IMPACTING
BUSINESSES AND OUR WORK FORCE
NEEDS?
SURE.
ANOTHER GOOD QUESTION AROUND HOW
WE THINK ABOUT AND SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT.
THE INTERSECTION OF THOSE GOALS
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC SUMMIT
CALLED THE TRIPLE BOTTOM LINE
AND YOU MENTIONED THAT IN YOUR
INTRODUCTORY.
HAVE PEOPLE USE DIFFERENT
TERMINOLOGY FOR WHAT THAT IS BUT
THE WAY I THINK ABOUT IT IS IT'S
SMART INVESTING AND SMART
BUSINESS IF YOU REALLY ARE THERE
FOR THE LONGER TERM WHAT YOU
WANT TO BE DOING IS YOU DON'T
WANT TO BE DESTROYING THE
ECONOMY AND THE ENVIRONMENT
AROUND.
YOU WHAT YOU WANT TO BE DOING IS
HELPING ENSURE THAT YOUR ACTIONS
LEAD TO A SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY
AND A HIGH QUALITY.
ENVIRONMENT AROUND YOU AND SO.
THE WHAT I THINK MOST BUSINESSES
LOOK FOR IN THAT REGARD IS
CLARITY AND CONSISTENCY OF WHAT
THE THE POLICIES ARE.
THEY CAN OPERATE AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THEY KNOW WHAT THE THE
RULES ARE AND WHAT THE THE
NATURE OF THE THE OPPORTUNITY IS
IN MOST OF THE REST OF THE WORLD.
CARBON IS PRICED INTO HOW WE HOW
THE BUSINESS IS DONE.
IN MANY BUSINESSES IN THIS STATE.
AND MANY BUSINESSES IN THIS
COUNTRY THEY'RE USING THAT FOR
THEIR DECISION MAKING ALREADY.
AND SO TRYING TO THINK ABOUT HOW
WE ENSURE THAT.
THAT ARE.
CLIMATE OBJECTIVES ARE LINED
WITH OUR BUSINESS OBJECTIVES IS
REALLY JUST SMART BUSINESS.
THANK YOU UNDER.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME I DO WANT
TO ASK YOU A QUESTION AS RELATES
TO PRIVATE CAPITAL DOES THE
STATE HAVE A GAME PLAN TO
ATTRACT PRIVATE CAPITAL --
WHEN IT COMES TO MEETING OUR
STATES INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS?
SO AB.
THERE ARE.
IT'S BOTH THE STATE QUESTION AND
A PRIVATE CAPITAL QUESTION
PRIVATE CAPITAL HAS ITS VIEWS
ABOUT WHERE IT WANTS TO GO.
AND SO WE CAN'T DO THAT IN THERE
ARE THEIR INTERESTS ARE WHAT
WOULD YOU DO IS ALIGN OUR POLICY.
TO ENSURE THAT THEIR INVESTMENTS
ARE ALIGNED WITH WHAT OUR
INTERESTS ARE SO THAT WAS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE QUESTION.
YOU ASKED ME A MINUTE TO GO
AROUND.
AND CARBON OBJECTIVES SO WHAT WE
REALLY WANT TO BE DOING IS
TRACKING INVESTMENT THAT IS
TRYING TO MEET THE STATE'S
CARBON GOALS.
TRYING TO MEET OUR HOUSING GOALS
AND TRYING TO MEET OUR HIGH
QUALITY WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
GOALS AND SO I THINK THOSE ARE
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE NEED.
TO ENSURE ARE ALIGNED --
THE THERE ARE ELEMENTS IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE
THAT ARE DOING THAT AND OUR
OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP MAKE SURE
THOSE TOOLS ARE WORKING TOGETHER.
TO HELP INCREASE THE
ATTRACTIVENESS FROM AN
INVESTMENT STANDPOINT FROM
COUPLE WANTS TO COME HERE AND
ENSURE THAT IT'S DEPLOYED TO
ACCOMPLISH THOSE THOSE STATE
POLICY OBJECTIVES.
THANKS FOR WHAT SEE THAT WE HAVE
NO FURTHER QUESTIONS I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TODAY AND SHARING YOUR NEW
POSITION WITHIN --
THE NEW SEVEN MINISTRATION AND
YOUR VIEWS ON HOW WE CAN CREATE
A MORE INCLUSIVE ECONOMY SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND I'M
SURE THAT --
WILL HAVE PLENTY TO DISCUSS OVER
THIS NEXT SESSION THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. FOR NEXT SPEAKER
DOCTOR HIS SHOES HERNANDEZ --
COULD COME.
TO THE TABLE I WILL PROVIDE A
BRIEF FRAME WORK ON THIS AGENDA
ITEM.
WITH AN ECONOMY LARGER THAN ALL
THE FOUR NATIONS IN THE WORLD IN
AND YOU'LL SEE BUDGET EXCEEDING
ONE HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN A
CULTURAL.
A CULTURE OF DIVERSITY AND
INNOVATION.
CALIFORNIA COULD BE READY TO
EMBRACE AN INCLUSIVE THE
DEVELOPMENT MODEL A MODEL THAT
BUILDS RESILIENCE RESILIENCY AND
SUPPORT TO REGIONAL AND
NEIGHBORHOOD PRIORITIES WHAT
CREATING COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGES
FOR BUSINESSES AND WORKERS ALIKE.
IMPLEMENTING THIS MODEL WILL
TAKE SOME NEW WAYS WE HAVE ASKED
OUR NEXT SPEAKER SPEAKER DOCTOR
HIS SHOES HERNANDEZ PRINCIPLE OF
J. C. H. RESEARCH TO HELP US
LOOK MORE DEEPLY AT WHAT IT WILL
TAKE TO SUPPORT.
AN INCLUSIVE DEVELOPMENT MODEL
BASED ON SUSTAINABLE PRINCIPLES
DOCTOR HERNANDEZ HAS SPENT HIS
CAREER DEVELOPING AND
IMPLEMENTING COMMUNITY BASED
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIES
HE'LL BE USING HIS WORK WITH THE
FRANKLY NEIGHBORHOOD IN
SACRAMENTO AS A REAL WORLD
EXAMPLE.
OF HOW LEGISLATION TRANSLATES TO
PRACTICE OUR DOCTORS MANTIS IF
YOU LIKE TO BE ON GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU ALL FOR HAVING ME
TODAY.
MY SHORT PRESENTATION WILL FOCUS.
ON HOW TO OPERATIONALIZE CLIMATE
CHANGE POLICY AT THE
NEIGHBORHOODS SCALE.
AND HOW WE CAN MOVE FORWARD.
AND CLOSER.
TOWARDS THE GOVERNOR'S QUEST FOR
MORE INCLUSIVE ECONOMY.
WE NOW HAVE AN ABUNDANCE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE MANDATES THAT FOCUS
ON ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP.
AND A KEY PART OF THIS
LEGISLATION AIMS TO ADDRESS ANY
QUALITY IN OUR CITIES.
SO POLICY NOW PLACES AN EMPHASIS
ON REPAIRING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES SO THEY CAN ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATE IN A NEW GREEN
ECONOMY [inaudible]
HOWEVER.
REGION'S IN MUNICIPALITIES ARE
NOT SURE HOW TO GO ABOUT THIS.
REGIONAL PLANNING IS NOT REALLY
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS THE CHANGING
NEEDS OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
SO THE IMPORTANT QUESTION HERE
IS HOW DO MUNICIPALITIES MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS INCLUSIVE
ECONOMY AGENDA.
AT ITS ROOT.
CLIMATE CHANGE LEGISLATION IS
BASED UPON THE CONCEPT OF
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGIES.
THE CONCEPT OF SUSTAINABILITY IS
VERY SIMPLE.
ACHIEVE AND MAINTAIN A BALANCE
OF ECONOMIC STEWARDSHIP.
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND EQUITY.
ALL OF OUR PUBLIC INVESTMENTS
MUST WORK TO MAINTAIN THIS
BALANCE WITHOUT COMPROMISING.
THE ABILITY TO MEET OUR FUTURE
NEEDS.
WE MUST ENCOURAGE ECONOMIC
GROWTH THROUGH AN EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION.
OF SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY.
IN THIS MANNER WE RESTORE AND
REVITALIZE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WHAT BRINGING
CAPACITY FOR RESILIENCE.
SO IN THIS MODEL.
THERE'S FIVE BASIC ELEMENTS THAT
ARE ESSENTIAL TO ACHIEVING
NEIGHBORHOOD SUSTAINABILITY.
EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT HOUSING
HEALTH CARE AND WILL THE
COMMUNITY IN OPPORTUNITIES.
WE MUST ALSO LOOK AT THE SOFT
AND HARD INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
CONNECTIVE TISSUE.
TRANSPORTATION ENERGY.
BUILDINGS ROADS BROADBAND EXCEPT.
FOR THESE TIED TOGETHER THOSE
FIVE IMPORTANT SOCIAL GOODS.
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL
INTERDEPENDENT IF ONE GOES BAD
THEY ALL GO BACK.
SO WHEN WE READ VALUE WAIT
NEIGHBORHOOD SYSTEMS WE SHOULD
ASK SOME VERY SIMPLE QUESTIONS.
ARE THESE NEIGHBORHOODS SYSTEMS
RELIABLE.
CAN I DEPEND ON WHAT NEEDS TO BE
RESTORED.
HOW DO WE FIX THAT?
AND ARE THEY RESILIENT.
HOW DO WE RECOVER [inaudible]
AND WITH TITLE SIX OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT.
ARE THESE PUBLIC INVESTMENTS
BEING USED TO REPAIR AND
REGENERATE THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS
LEFT BEHIND.
THIS IS THE ANALYTICAL LANDS
THAT ENSURES THAT WE INCLUDE ALL
NEIGHBORHOODS IN CLIMATE CHANGE.
WHEN WE USE THIS APPROACH PUBLIC
INVESTMENT STRATEGIES FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES BECOME
RESTORATIVE REGENERATIVE BY
DESIGN?
ECONOMIC INVESTMENT PRESERVES
OUR NATURAL RESOURCES.
WHILE PROVIDING SOCIAL
PROTECTIONS IN MARKET ACCESS TO
ALL NEIGHBORHOODS.
I WANT TO STRESS THAT THIS MEANS
WE USED THE NEIGHBORHOOD AS AN
IMPORTANT UNIT OF ANALYSIS.
IT'S A LAYER OF GOVERNANCE
THAT'S MISSING FROM THE
SUSTAINABILITY EQUATION.
AS WELL AS THE DEBATE.
NOW TO DEMONSTRATE THE POTENTIAL
OF THIS LEGISLATIVE CLIMATE
CHANGE TOOL KIT.
I USE A CASE STUDY OF THE
FRANKLIN NEIGHBORHOOD IN SOUTH
SACRAMENTO.
OUR GOALS ARE VERY SIMPLE.
G. H. T. REDUCTION [inaudible]
NEIGHBORHOOD STABILIZATION.
OUR TARGETS FOSSIL FUEL TRANSIT.
GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE AND MOST
IMPORTANT HUMAN CAPITAL
INVESTMENT.
I STRATEGIES MULTI MODAL TRANSIT
TREATING PUBLIC SPACE.
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND CRADLE TO
CAREER NETWORKS.
NOW WE HAVE THE FOUNDATION. FOR
MOVING INTO A NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND THIS IS HOW IT WORKS.
WE RECENTLY ONE OF GRANT FOR A
COMPLETE STREETS REDESIGNED
WHICH IS OUR FOUNDATION FOR A
DEFICIENT MULTI MODAL TRANSIT
NETWORK.
WILL ADDRESS HEAT MITIGATION
CREATE PUBLIC SPACE WITH A GREEN
CANOPY PROMOTE SAFETY AND HEALTH
INCREASE RESIDENT BUSINESS
CONNECTIVITY AND HAVE A POSITIVE
ECONOMIC HEALTH ENVIRONMENTAL
EFFECT.
PEOPLE PLACE AND PLANTED.
THIS ALLOWS US TO LEVERAGE
TRANSIT INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
HOUSING AND TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES AS
HOUSING.
IS LEVERAGED AND COMPLIMENTS THE
NEW GREEN STREET SCAPE.
THE NEIGHBORHOOD RECENTLY WON A
TRANSFORMATION --
TRANSFORMING CLIMATE COMMUNITIES
PLANNING GRANT FOR THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL.
AND IT JUST ALLOWS US TO
CONTINUE THE NEIGHBORHOOD
PLANNING AT THE NEIGHBORHOODS
SCALE.
THIS WE CAN BEGIN TO SEE THE
MULTIPLE WAYS THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE LEGISLATION CAN BE USED
TO REVITALIZE A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY.
WE COMPLEMENT IS GREEN STREET
SCAPE WITH THE NEIGHBORHOOD
SHUTTLE THAT PROVIDES INTERNAL
CONNECTIVITY TO THE BUSINESS COR
EXTERNAL CONNECTIVITY TO
REGIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND WE
REDUCE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED BY
CONNECTING TO LIGHT RAIL.
AND BUS LINES ONE REVITALIZING
THE BUSINESS CORE.
AND WE CONNECT THE DOTS WITH
SOLAR PARKING LOT CANOPIES.
AT THE NEIGHBORHOOD RESOURCE
CENTER WE RECENTLY GRANT
[inaudible] TO DESIGN NEW TYPES
OF SOLAR ARRAYS EASING TENSION
WIRES RATHER THAN IN THE GROUND
TYPE OF FOUNDATIONS.
THIS ALLOWS US FOR LOCAL FOR A
TWO THIS ALLOWS US LOCAL
RENEWABLE ENERGY.
GENERATION WAS STORAGE ALLOWS
FOR MICHAEL GOOD TO PASS CITY
FOR DISASTER RECOVERY PLANS A
HEAT COOLING CENTER OF JOB
TRAINING IN THE INDUSTRY ENERGY
INDUSTRY AND HAS PUBLIC HEALTH.
PROVIDES CHARGING FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND REDUCES THE COST OF
ENERGY TO THE TENANTS AND AT
THAT THE PROPERTY.
AND THIS SITE ALSO BECOMES AN
IMPORTANT RESEARCH LOCATION.
FORTY POINT DISTRIBUTIVE ON
DEMAND ENERGY CONCEPTS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND WE ALSO WANT TO FIVE MILLION
GRAY --
DOLLAR GRANT. FOR WEATHERIZATION
AND ROOF TOP SELLERS.
WE SCALE THIS UP.
BY RE PURPOSING BLIGHTED LAND
FOR LARGE SCALE SOLAR ENERGY
PROJECTS THAT BECOME
NEIGHBORHOOD INFRASTRUCTURE.
OUR SOLAR PROJECT BECOMES A SITE
FOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AS
WELL AS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN
ADDITION TO AN ELEVEN ACRE SOLAR
ARRAY WE ALSO PROVIDE PUBLIC
SPACE WITH A ONE ACRE COVERED
SORT OF CANOPY AS WELL AS
FOOTBALL AND SOCCER FIELDS FOR
THE YOUTH LEAGUES.
WE ADDRESS ENVIRONMENTAL PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS BY PRODUCING
RENEWABLE ENERGY FOR SALE TO THE
LOCAL UTILITY COMPANY.
AND THIS CREATES A NEIGHBORHOOD
GENERATED UNRESTRICTED REVENUE
SOURCE.
WHICH IS THEN REINVESTED IN
NEIGHBORHOOD HEALTH CARE AND
THIS IS A REPUTABLE BUSINESS
MODEL THAT CAN BE PLAYED IN ANY
TACK.
AND WE CONTINUE TO CONNECT THE
DOTS WITH A DECENTRALIZED
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM FUNDED BY
SOLAR ENERGY REVENUES THAT
MATCHES MATCHES UNIVERSITY
PRECEPTOR TRAINING PROGRAMS OF
VIRTUAL HEALTH CARE.
VIRTUAL HEALTHCARE DELIVERY AND
ALLIED HEALTH PROGRAMS THAT
CREATE AXIS FOR NEIGHBORHOOD
RESIDENTS TO HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
AS WELL AS HEALTH INDUSTRY
EMPLOYMENT.
AGAIN THE GOAL IS TO LEVERAGE
CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT INVESTMENT TO CREATE
A NEIGHBORHOOD FOCUSED
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT LEADS TO RENEWABLE ENERGY
PRODUCTION.
NEIGHBORHOOD CLEAN ENERGY
OPTIONS HEALTH CARE ACCES JOBS
AND TRAINING HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES AT REHABILITATE
AND INCREASE OUR HOUSING STOCK.
SO THERE'S A LOGIC TO ALL OF
THIS.
THROUGH DIRECT NEIGHBORHOOD
INVESTMENT WE SEE JOBS
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP
BUILDING AND WE BUILD CAPACITY
FOR PROJECTS.
WE SEE TO RECTIFY X. TO
BUSINESSES AND HOUSEHOLDS IN
SAVINGS INDIRECT EFFECTS INCLUDE
INCREASED NEIGHBORHOOD SPENDING.
BUSINESS AND JOB RETENTION AND
WE MEET OUR TARGET OF
NEIGHBORHOOD SUSTAINABILITY
STABILIZE IN OUR BUSINESSES
AVOIDING DISPLACEMENT AND THE
LOSS OF EXISTING JOBS.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY NOW
BECOMES AN ACTIVE PARTICIPATION
PARTICIPANT AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
SO IF WE WANT TO MOVE FORWARD.
WITH THE INCLUSIVE ECONOMY.
WE NEED ENERGY POLICY THAT
ENCOURAGES.
TAX OR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
TO PARTICIPATE IN ENERGY MARKETS
AS PRODUCERS NOT AS DEPENDENT.
DEPENDENCE ON UTILITY SUBSIDIES.
WE NEED TRANSIT POLICY THAT
BRINGS TRANSIT TO HOUSING.
RATHER THAN HOUSING TO TRANSIT.
WE NEED HOUSING POLICIES THAT
FINANCIALLY SUPPORT NEIGHBORHOOD
SPECIFIC NEEDS.
WE NEED TO STRIP IT OF HEALTH
CARE DELIVERY THAT BRINGS ACCESS
TO THOSE WHO NEED IT THE MOST.
IF WE WANT TO MOVE TOWARDS THIS
INCLUSIVE ECONOMY WE SHOULD
RECOGNIZE THAT REGIONAL PLANTS
ARE NOT REALLY DESIGNED TO SOLVE
THIS NEIGHBORHOOD DISTRICTS.
INVESTMENT READY PROJECTS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT OVERLAP
WITH OPPORTUNITIES ONS REQUIRED
INTENSIVE AMOUNT OF PLANNING.
NEIGHBORHOOD SPECIFIC PLANNING
IS ESSENTIAL TO ACHIEVING THOSE
GOALS BUT THERE IS VIRTUALLY NO
FUNDING FOR SUCH TYPE.
THE TRANSFORMING KEL CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES IS A GOOD START.
BUT REQUIRES MUCH MORE FUNDING
TO BRING THIS CONCEPT TO SCALE.
AND LOCAL AGENCIES NEED TO NEED
RESOURCES TO CREATE THE
DECENTRALIZED PLANNING
MECHANISMS NEEDED FOR
NEIGHBORHOOD PLANNING.
WE JUST SIMPLY CANNOT DO THIS
ONE NEIGHBORHOOD AT A TIME.
SO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE DO THIS
RIGHT.
WE HAVE NEIGHBORHOOD SPECIFIC
INFRASTRUCTURE BECOMES A
PRIORITY BEFORE EXTERNAL PROFIT.
WE SEE JOBS AND ENERGY HEALTH
TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING WE
AVOID DISPLACEMENT WE AVOID
GENTRIFICATION AS PEOPLE WILL
STAND OR NEIGHBORHOODS.
WE SEE EDUCATIONAL VOCATIONAL
EDUCATIONAL AND VOCATIONAL
PATHWAYS AND MOST IMPORTANT WE
BEGIN TO MEET OUR TITLE SIX
OBLIGATIONS FOR EQUAL
DISTRIBUTION OF PUBLIC FUNDS.
THIS IS HOW WE CAN CONNECT THE
DOTS BETWEEN CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICY.
AND REVITALIZING OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR HERNANDEZ.
I WILL START OFF.
WITH A QUICK QUESTION BEFORE
OPENING UP TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HOW DO YOU RECOMMEND MODIFYING --
CITY PLANNING MODELS TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS.
A VERY GOOD START WAS SB ONE
THOUSAND THAT REQUIRES
MUNICIPALITIES TO INCLUDE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE BECAUSE
JUSTICE COMPONENTS INTO THEIR
GENERAL PLAN.
THIS IS REALLY AT THE HEART OF
THIS CONNECTION BETWEEN
MUNICIPALITIES.
AND NEIGHBORHOODS.
MISS ABOUT THESE DO NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO SCALE DOWN TO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
THEY PLANNED FOR BIG TICKET
ITEMS LIKE ARENAS AND DOWNTOWN
DEVELOPMENT.
AND THEY DO VERY GOOD AT IT.
BUT THERE HAS TO BE A BALANCE
BETWEEN WHAT HAPPENS.
IN THESE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND HOW TO MAKE THE
LEGISLATION OPERATIONAL.
SO THEY NEED MORE RESOURCES TO
DO THIS TYPE OF PLANNING.
AND THAT SHOULD BE BUILT INTO
THESE GENERAL PLANS AT THE
MUNICIPALITY LEVEL.
THANK YOU AND WHAT AND WHAT
WOULD YOU SAY ARE THE MOST
IMPORTANT NEXT STEPS THE STATE
CAN TAKE.
I TO SUPPORT OF MORE MOVE UPWARD
MOBILITY WITHIN AT THE SAME
NEIGHBORHOODS.
AT THE STATE LEVEL.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A A MECHANISM
WHERE WE ACTUALLY.
PUT A PRIORITY ON NEIGHBORHOOD
SCALE PLANNING.
WE HAVE LEVELS OF GOVERNANCE.
STATE REGION MUNICIPALITY AS AN
HOUSEHOLD WE MISS THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD CONCEPT.
THAT MEANS THE PENALTIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR BUT HAVE NO
RESOURCES [inaudible] TO ADDRESS.
SO -- WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THINGS LIKE THE
TRANSFORM IF TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES THAT THAT
DOES STRATEGIC LOWER GROWTH
COUNCIL IS CURRENTLY IN CHARGE
OF I NEED A LOT MORE MONEY TO
SCALE THESE PROJECTS UP.
PEOPLE ACTUALLY WANT TO PLAY
AGAIN ALL THIS WORK THAT YOU SEE
DOWN HERE THIS THIS IS THREE
YEARS OF WORK. FOR FREE.
NEIGHBORHOODS CAN AFFORD THIS
KIND OF WORK.
AND THAT IS THE ONLY WAY THESE
MODELS BECOME COME TO THE
SURFACE BECAUSE THE REALITY IS
IS THAT IF WE CAN'T PERCOLATE
PROJECTS FROM BELOW.
WE CAN'T WRITE THE GRASS FUND.
NOBODY FUNDS THEM BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T SEE THE AND PLANNING IS
THE KEY. TO THAT HAPPENING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ASSEMBLYMEMBER REQUEST.
THANK YOU DOCTOR HERNANDEZ SOME.
YOU KNOW ONE COMMUNITY IN MY
DISTRICT JUST RECEIVE THE
TRANSFORMING CLIMATE COMMUNITIES
GRANT --
PACOIMA WHICH IS WHERE I GREW UP --
AND A LOT OF WHAT YOU PRESENTED --
IT SEEMS LIKE WITH THE PLAN FOR
THAT PROJECT IS SIMILAR --
SO I'M VERY EXCITED TO SEE --
YOUR PRESENTATION --
AND BUT DO YOU THINK WITH PROP
YOU KNOW MUNICIPALITIES DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO PLAN.
BUT I'M I'M HOPING THAT THESE
PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING FUNDED
CAN SERVE AS EXAMPLES AS AS A
PLACE THAT YOU CAN GO AND SEE IT
ONCE THESE PROJECTS ARE
COMPLETED --
AND THEN HIGHLIGHT THE NEED OF
NEIGHBORHOOD SKILLS.
YES -- AND
ONE QUESTION I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
YOU.
HOW MANY NEIGHBORHOODS IN YOUR
AREA WOULD BENEFIT FROM THAT
TYPE OF GRANT?
ALL OF THEM AND SO WILL WE CAN
ONLY DO IT ONE NEIGHBORHOOD AT A
TIME IN MORE DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE STATE IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
SCALE THIS URGENCY UP.
WITHOUT THE RESOURCES TO REALLY
ROLL OUT WHAT WE CALL CLIMATE
CHANGE POLICY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH --
DOCTRINE AND IS FOR BEING HERE
ARE YOU MISSION --
THAT WE SHOULD BRING TRANSIT TO
HOUSING AND ALL AND THAT'S A
VERY FASCINATING CONCEPT I AM
JUST WONDERING UP.
OCCASIONALLY WE SAY WE ARMED
BUILT AROUND TRANSIT FOR EXAMPLE
IS WHEN IT COMES TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND THE LIKE SO ARE WE
HAVE BE WE'VE BEEN DOING IT
BACKWARDS--
OR IS THAT NOT THE CASE
[inaudible]
SO.
WHAT WE DO IS WE LOOK AT WHERE
TRANSIT IS LOCATED?
N. HISTORICALLY TRANSIT IS NOT
LOCATED IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
WHICH ELIMINATES THEM FROM ANY
KIND OF TRANSITORY DEVELOPMENT
FUND.
WHICH MEANS WE SKEW WHERE THIS
MONEY GO THIS AND IT DOESN'T
TAKE CARE OF THE OBJECTIVES OF
THE LEGISLATION WHICH IS SAYS.
GET TO THE DACS GET TO THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
IMPLEMENT THESE CLIMATE CHANGE
TOLLS.
BUT WHEN IT OPERATES ON THE
GROUND.
WE HAVE THESE RULES THAT SAY YOU
CAN ONLY DO THIS WHERE TRANSIT
IS LOCATED.
WHICH WIPES OUT MY NEIGHBORHOOD
FROM THE PROCESS SO HOW DO WE
GET MORE DISTRIBUTIVE TYPES OF
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS THAT GO
INTO THE NEIGHBORHOODS AND
CIRCULATE WITH IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS.
BECAUSE MOST OF OUR TRAVEL IS
WITHIN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
IN THIS I HAVE TO GO TO THE
DOCTOR BECAUSE THERE'S NO
HEALTHCARE IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD I
GOT TO GO TO A BIG BOX OUT IN
ROCKLIN IN ANOTHER PLACE.
SO BY HAVING THIS TYPE OF
HOUSING.
THAT IS SUPPORTED BY A MORE
NIMBLE TYPE OF TRANSPORTATION.
I CAN QUALIFY FOR TRANSIT
ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT FUNDS AND
GET THE HOUSING I NEED YOU MY
COMPLETE STREETS PROJECT. TO
MAKE THAT SYNCHRONICITY
[inaudible]
STREETS.
HOUSING PEOPLE WALK WALK ABILITY
EVERYTHING THAT WE WANT TO SEE
THE DOWNTOWN EXPERIENCE THERE'S
NO REASON YOU CAN'T HAVE THAT IN
A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY.
SOME REMEMBER RAMOS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR ON THE THE SOLAR
ASPECT OF IT AND INTO THE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY HOW MUCH OF THAT WENT
BACK INTO THE LOCAL --
COMMUNITY ITSELF AND DID THE END
USERS IN THAT LOCAL COMMUNITY
AND UP --
BENEFITING FROM THAT COMING BACK
I AM VERY HAPPY YOU BROUGHT THIS
QUESTION TEMAS TO THIS COMMITTEE.
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WE'RE HAVING
IN ROLLING OUT THAT PROJECT.
IS ACCESSING CAP AND TRADE
DOLLARS.
AS THE WAY CAP AND TRADE
POLICIES ARE WRITTEN THEY'RE
WRITTEN.
FOR ALMOST LIKE A SUBSIDY TO THE
HOUSEHOLD WHENEVER WE PUT UP A
SOLAR ARRAY.
IT HAS TO RESULT IN A DIRECT
REDUCTION AND HOUSEHOLD UTILITY
COSTS.
NOW WHEN THE UTILITY COMPANY TAX
ON A THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR
APPLICATION FEE FOR THOSE
PARTIES WE WIPE OUT THE WE BY
ABOUT THE SAVINGS.
WHICH MEANS WE CANNOT PROVIDE
THAT SERVICE.
AND ALSO WHEN WE FOCUS ON THE
RATHER THAN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
THE GRASS DON'T ALLOW US TO
AGGREGATE THE ENERGY
[inaudible] TO SELL.
BUT RATHER AS THE INTERNET WANT
A SUBSIDY TO THE HOUSEHOLD SO
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO BUILD THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT THING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
NOW I HAVE TO GO SEEK PRIVATE
FINANCING FOR THIS.
AT A HIGHER INTEREST RATE.
THAN WHAT I WAS BE GETTING FROM --
THE STATE ON CAP AND TRADE
DOLLARS.
SO EVEN THOUGH THE THE MODEL
SEEMS TO BE WORKING YOU HAVE --
SOLAR PANELS COMING UP TENSION
WIRES OF I UNDERSTOOD IT
CORRECTLY NOT YES THAT'S AT THAT
THE MENTION THE PARKING LOT
CANOPY WHO WERE AT THE COMMUNITY
CENTER THAT WERE THE AND THE THE
NEIGHBORHOOD GETTING THE
DISTRIBUTIVE ENERGY STILL AS A
COMPONENT THAT NEEDS TO BE
WORKED ON SO THAT.
THE END RESULT IS THERE IN THE
NAVY IS THERE THE IDEA NOW IS
HOW DO WE CHANGE THIS DIALOGUE
THAT EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENS IN
A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY HAS TO
GO TO A HOUSEHOLD.
RATHER THAN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
THE LEGISLATION SAYS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY IT DOES
NOT SAY DISADVANTAGED HOUSEHOLD.
AND WHAT HAPPENS IS WE LOSE
THESE INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO TURN THIS
OVER AS A SUBSIDY TO THESE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THAT'S DOING OF GREAT INJUSTICE.
IF WE CAN TOUCH ON TRACKING
PROGRESS IN MEASURING WHAT
MATTERS WHAT WOULD YOU SAY THAT
WE SHOULD DO AS A STATE TO
MODIFY EXISTING OR A DOT NEW.
METRICS THAT TRACK PROGRESS SAID
IT ENCOURAGE UPWARD MOBILITY IN
AN AN INCLUSIVE ECONOMY.
IF IF THE STATE.
WOULD LIKE.
TO CHAU WHO ITS PROGRESS.
WE REALLY NEED TOMORROW MARCH OR
WHERE THE MONEY ACTUALLY CUTS
HOW MUCH OF THIS CAP AND TRADE
DOLLARS ACTUALLY HIT
NEIGHBORHOODS.
NOT JUST BECAUSE WE'RE DOING AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT THAT
ONE DEVELOPER GETS BUT HOW DO
THESE PROJECTS REALLY HIT THE
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE THEY GIVING ME
THE HOUSING PRODUCTS THAT MY
NEIGHBORHOOD NEEDS.
MY NEIGHBORHOOD DOESN'T NEED
ANOTHER BIG BOX.
APARTMENT COMPLEXES WHERE SOME
OUTSIDE OWNER OWNS AND PULLS
RENTS FROM THE NEIGHBORHOODS.
WE NEED AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
I MEAN WE NEED AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP.
AND HOMEOWNERSHIP IS THE KEY.
IF WE CAN'T PROVIDE THAT
HOMEOWNERSHIP PEOPLE LEAVE THE
NEIGHBORHOODS WE WANT THAT
HOMEOWNERSHIP THAT'S AFFORDABLE.
AND MEETS THE NEEDS THAT OF OF
THE PEOPLE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
TO COMPLEMENT THESE OTHER
CLIMATE CHANGE ACTIVITIES LIKE
THE COMPLETE STREETS PROJECT
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS ENERGY
PROJECTS THAT WERE PULLING THE
HEALTH CARE PRODUCTS THAT WOULD
BRING IT.
WELL TO STAY THERE.
AND WE CAN'T KEEP IN THERE IS
RENTERS.
SO WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW WE
FUND.
AND SUPPORT FINANCIALLY.
HOUSING AT THE STATE LEVEL WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THE TYPES OF
HOUSING PRODUCTS WE ARE
SUPPORTING.
ARE WE SUPPORTING THE TYPES OF
HOUSING PRODUCTS.
THAT ACTUALLY BRING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES INTO
THIS NEW INCLUSIVE ECONOMY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT RESPONSE.
NOT SEEN ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK YOU
DOCTOR HERNANDEZ YOUR PHONINESS
TODAY.
AND I LOOK FOR TO CERTAINLY
WORKING WITH YOU THROUGHOUT THE
SESSION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WONDERFUL SO GIVEN THAT WE ARE
EXTREMELY WELL ON TIME TODAY --
I WILL GO AHEAD AND BRING UP OUR
NEXT PANEL I TWO PRESENTS IF YOU
CAN PLEASE JOIN US AT THE TABLE.
WE HAVE DR.
LOUIS SAID THAT'S WORTH.
THROUGH BOW HAND AND LAURIE
BERMAN.
IN THIS FINAL PANEL WE ARE GOING
TO DELVE MORE DEEPLY INTO
EXISTING PROGRAMS I CAN
SUPPORTER UPWARD MOBILITY.
AN INDEPENDENT ECONOMIC SECURITY
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF THE
STATE'S OTHER CORE
RESPONSIBILITIES INCLUDING
CLIMATE CHANGE MITIGATION.
DIVERSIFICATION OF THE STATE'S
ENERGY SOURCES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT
WHAT'S DRIVING IT TOWARD THESE
GOALS THESE PROGRAMS CAN ALSO.
PROVIDE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITIES TO
ELEMENT IN ENTREPRENEURSHIP WE
WILL ALSO LEARN HOW AT THE
MANAGEMENT AND REGULATORY LEVEL
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE HAD TO
EVOLVE IN ORDER TO ENSURE A
DIVERSE RANGE OF BUSINESSES.
GRANTEES IN NEIGHBORHOODS CAN
BENEFIT WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO
WELCOME EACH OF YOU --
TO TODAY'S HEARING WE HAVE
LOUISE VETS FURRED DOCTOR BEDS
FOR ITS EXACTLY DIRECTOR OF THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNSEL WITH US
THROUGH BOTH HAND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION.
AND LAURIE BERMAN DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION.
HOW WE LOOK FORTY HEARING FROM
EACH OF YOU --
WE VALUE OUR WITNESSES
PRESENTATIONS AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE AN OFFER GREAT INSIGHT TO
TO US TODAY ON HOW
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND WORKFORCE.
TRAINING ARE BEING INTEGRATED
WITHIN THE EACH OF THESE
PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO ADVANCE A
PROSPEROUS AND MORE INCLUSIVE
ECONOMY.
I LET ME JUST SAY THAT IT IS AN
HONOR TO HAVE EACH OF YOU WITH
THIS TODAY AND WE CAN GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN WITH DOCTOR BUT IT'S
WORTH.
GREAT THANK YOU --
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S LOUISE
BEDS WORTH TIME THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL --
AND THAT PRESENTATION ACTUALLY
WAS A VERY NICE LEAD IN --
TWO AND I'LL TALK ABOUT TODAY --
BUT I'LL START JUST WITH A BIT
OF BACKGROUND --
THE CALIFORNIA STRATEGIC GROWTH
STATE STATUTE IN. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT TO SUPPORT THE PLANNING
AND DEVELOPMENT OF SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THE COUNCIL IS MADE UP OF TEN
MEMBERS WE HAVE SIX CABINET
SECRETARIES OF REPRESENTING SIX
AGENCIES THE DIRECTOR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH AND THREE PUBLIC
MEMBERS ONE APPOINTED BY.
THE ASSEMBLY OF THE SENATE AND
THE GOVERNOR.
AND OUR COUNCIL CHAIRED BY THE
DIRECTOR OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
SO AS YOU SEE THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL WORKS THROUGH ITS
MEMBERS AND IT'S AGENCIES TO
ACHIEVE IN ADVANCE COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS TO SHAPE --
HOW AND WHERE WE'RE GROWING AND
TO ACHIEVE HEALTHY EQUITABLE AND
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES AND
LANDSCAPES FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS --
WE REALIZE THIS VISION THROUGH
COLLABORATIVE POLICY INITIATIVES
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
CAPACITY BUILDING AND
COMMUNITIES.
AND INVESTMENT AND SUSTAINABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT
LINK TRANSPORTATION HOUSING AND
OTHER COMMUNITY BENEFITS --
THAT REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BUT ALSO IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ACT EQUITY
OUTCOMES.
M. THROUGHOUT ALL OF OUR WORK WE
EMPHASIZE --
AND FOCUS ON SUPPORTING LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
SINCE ITS CREATION THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCILS INVESTED OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS IN PLANNING AND
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE --
THAT HAVE RESULTED IN
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION AND
HOUSING PROJECTS AND OVER HALF
OF THESE INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN
MADE IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
SO REALLY CENTRAL TO ACHIEVING
OUR VISION AT STC AS THAT ALL
POP COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE ARE
PART OF THE SOLUTION --
AND BENEFIT FROM INVESTMENT BUT
ALSO REALLY IMPORTANTLY THAT
WERE EMPOWERING AND SUPPORTING
COMMUNITIES DEVELOP THEIR OWN
VISION OF PROSPEROUS EQUITABLE
AND SUSTAINABLE FUTURE.
AND THAT TOGETHER WE CAN REALIZE
OUR GOALS.
SO WE LEAD WORK IN SEVERAL AREAS --
INCLUDING THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM I MENTIONED WE ALSO DO A
LOT OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE --
BUT TODAY I'LL TALK MORE ABOUT
OUR TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAMS I THINK IT
REALLY SPEAKS TO A LOT OF THAT --
THE FOCUS OF TODAY'S HEARING.
THE TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM WHICH WE
HEARD A BIT ABOUT A PLANNING
GRANT THAT'S UNDER WAY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IN THE FRANKLIN
BOULEVARD AREA --
THIS TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMBING
COMMITTEES PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED THROUGH STATE
STATUTE IN --
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND IT WAS
DESIGNED TO REALIZE
ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMIC AND
PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS TO THE
STATE'S MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES --
TRANSFERRED OF CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES MAKES LARGE
INVESTMENTS IN INTER CONNECTED
TO SETS OF PROJECTS AT A
NEIGHBORHOOD SCALE THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO ACHIEVE A LOCAL
VISIONS THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
A COMMUNITY LED VISION FOR
TRANSFORMATION.
SO REALLY COMES FROM THE GROUND
UP --
TRANSFORM A CLIMATE COMMUNITIES
IS FUNDED THROUGH THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FIND.
AND IT IS DESIGNED TO CATALYZE
TRANSFORMATION SO IT IS REALLY
INTENDED TO BE A SEED.
THROUGH WHICH WE CAN --
LEVERAGE OTHER INVESTMENT ON THE
STATE'S MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN AREAS THAT HAVE
FOLK HAVE EXPERIENCE HISTORIC
UNDER INVESTMENT --
AND DISCONNECTION.
SO WE'VE CONDUCTED TWO ROUNDS OF
THE PROGRAM TODAY --
AM THROUGH EACH ROUND WE HAVE
IMPORTED A SMALL SET OF
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS AND
PLANNING GRANTS --
IN BOTH OF THESE ROUNDS WE
FOCUSED ON THE TOP 5% OF MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS DEFINED BY COUNTY VIRUS
SCREEN.
I WE'VE AWARDED FIVE
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS WHICH I'LL
TOUCH ON AND THEN ALSO FOURTEEN
PLANNING GRANTS --
OF WHICH THAT FRANKLIN BOULEVARD
NEIGHBORHOOD PROJECT IS AN
EXAMPLE.
THE PROGRAM IS REALLY BEEN
REALLY THOUGHTFULLY DESIGNED TO
INTEGRATE SOCIAL ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSIDERATIONS AND
AS I SAID REALLY IS DESIGNED TO
SUPPORT A COMMUNITY LEAD TO
VISION --
BUT ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT MANY
OF THESE COMMUNITIES DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE --
THE PROGRAM IS ALSO BEEN
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO ALL COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM.
AND THEN ULTIMATELY TO A
WARRANTIES THEY WILL ALSO
RECEIVE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THAT WE WE PROVIDE TO HELP ON
IMPLEMENTATION --
SO TO DATE ARE WARDS HAVE RANGED
FROM TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS UP TO SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS --
IN OUR IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS.
EACH AWARD IS UNIQUE BECAUSE AS
I MENTIONED IT'S DESIGNED TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF A COMMUNITY --
IT BUT IT IN THAT IS DEVELOPED
THROUGH A COLLABORATIVE
STAKEHOLDER STRUCTURE SO TO DATE
WE'VE INVESTED IN FIVE
NEIGHBORHOODS SCALE INVESTMENTS --
ONE IN FRESNO --
WHERE THEY WERE SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO FOCUS ON
PROJECTS IN WEST AND SOUTHWEST
FRESNO? THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE WATTS
NEIGHBORHOOD IN LOS ANGELES --
TO SUPPORT REDEVELOPMENT OF THE
JORDAN DOWNS HOUSING PROJECT AND
THE SURROUNDING NEIGHBORHOOD.
THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONTARIO TO SUPPORT DEVELOPMENT
IN DOWNTOWN ON TERRIO THROUGH AN
INITIATIVE CALLED ON TERRIO
TOGETHER.
THOSE ARE ALL OF OUR AROUND ONE
AWARDS IN WHICH WE AWARDED JUST
UNDER A HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WE AWARDED OUR ROUNDS TWO AWARDS
ONE TWO SACRAMENTO IN THAT TWIN
RIVERS AREA FOCUSED AROUND THE
DOSE RIOS LIGHT RAIL STATION.
AND THEN ONE TYPICAL EMMA --
TO SUPPORT COMMUNITY LED WORK
THAT'S BEEN --
UNDER WAY AND THAT COMMUNITY FOR
QUITE SOME TIME --
SO EACH AS I MENTION EACH
PROGRAM EACH PROJECT IS UNIQUE
AND EXACTLY WHAT THE SPECIFIC
INVESTMENTS ARE BUT I WANT TO
FOCUS ON COMMON ELEMENTS OF THE
PROGRAM THAT ARE IN PLACE TO
ENSURE.
EQUITABLE AND INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC
OUTCOMES FROM THESE INVESTMENTS.
FIRST IS EVERY PROJECT IS
CENTERED AROUND A COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT PLAN --
SO THEY NOTED EVERY AND AT THE
HEART OF IT IS THIS COMMUNITY
LED DIVISION.
AND SO EACH APPLICANT MUST
OUTLINED HOW THE COMMUNITY HAS
BEING BEEN ENGAGED LEADING UP TO
AND THEN FOLLOWING THROUGH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AWARD.
AND IN THE PROJECT AND WE
PROVIDE -- A
LOT OF ASSISTANCE MANY OF THEM
ARE DOING THAT ARE READY BUT
AGAIN PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO HELP
THEM TO DEVELOP.
THE RESOURCES AND APPROACHES TO
DO THAT.
EACH APPLICANT --
NEEDS TO DEVELOP A WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN SO --
TO SHOW HOW THEY'RE GOING TO USE
THIS INVESTMENT --
TO PROVIDE TRAINING AND
EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES AND THIS IS
IN SOME CASES THIS INCLUDES
LOCAL HIGHER REQUIREMENTS WHERE
WE'RE SEEING JOB TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES TO REALLY COMPLETE
THE FUNDED INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS --
IN OTHER AREAS WE'VE SEEN --
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS IN
BUSINESS INCUBATOR SERVICES.
AND WE WORK WITH THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD ON THAT ASPECT.
IN ADDITION REALLY IN CENTRAL TO
THIS -- EACH
PROJECT IS ALSO SO IN --
THAT THESE INVESTMENTS IN THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS BENEFIT THE PEOPLE
AND BUSINESSES THAT LIVE THERE.
NOW -- AND
WILL STAY IN THE FUTURE --
EACH APPLICANT MUST DEVELOP AN
ANTI DISPLACEMENT PLAN THAT
OUTLINES POLICIES AND
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE TO PREVENT
DISPLACEMENT OF RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES --
AND AGAIN WE WORK WITH EACH OF
THEM --
AROUND THAT.
AND THEN FINALLY EACH --
APPLICATION EACH PROJECT IS
REQUIRED TO HAVE AT LEAST 50%
LEVERAGE INVESTMENT --
AND SO WE ASK FOR IT THAT IS
TIED TO SPECIFIC PROJECTS IN THE
PRIDE AND THE INVESTMENT AREA.
SO FOR OUR FUTURE SKEWS ME
THROUGH OUR FIRST TWO ROUNDS OF
THE PROGRAM WE'VE INVEST
INVESTED JUST OVER A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
IN THESE FIVE NEIGHBORHOODS BUT
IF SEEN ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
LEVERAGE INVESTMENT THAT'S TIED
TO OTHER PROJECTS IN WITH IN OUR
PROJECT AREAS.
ARE PROJECT AREA IS FOCUS AT A
NEIGHBORHOOD SCALE SO AN AREA OF
LESS THAN FIVE SQUARE MILES. TO
REALLY ENSURE THAT YOU'RE SEEING
THE SYNERGIES AND BY --
JUST NOTED IN THE PREVIOUS
PRESENTATION MANY OF THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT COMPETITIVE --
INTO AN EXISTING PROGRAMS THE
THEY DON'T HAVETHE
TRANSPORTATION AMENITIES ARE
OTHER FACTORS THAT WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO ACCESS OTHER STATE FUNDS.
SO IN MANY CASES THIS INITIAL
INVESTMENT IS SETTING THEM UP TO
BE MUCH MORE COMPETITIVE FOR
FUTURE FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES.
AN EXCELLENT EXAMPLE OF THAT IS
THE SACRAMENTO AWARD WE JUST
MADE --
WHERE WERE A LOT OF OUR
INVESTMENTS GOING INTO THE DOES
RIOS LIGHT RAIL STATION WHICH
WILL MAKE THEM HAVE A HIGH
QUALITY TRANSIT CONNECTION?
THAT WILL MAKE THEM MORE
COMPETITIVE FOR OTHER AWARDS --
AND SO.
THIS PROGRAM TO US IS REALLY ONE
WE'VE WORKED VERY HARD AND WE
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
COMMUNITIES --
AS I MENTIONED WE'VE DEVELOPED --
WE ALSO PROVIDE PLANNING GRANTS
WE'VE AWARDED.
PLANNING GRANTS BETWEEN ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY AND TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
FOURTEEN COMMUNITIES --
AND WE HAVE EXPANDED THAT TO BE
NOT JUST THE TOP 5% OF MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES BUT IT
ALSO.
EXTENDS THE TOP 25% OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND THE INTENTION THERE IS THAT
WE'RE CREATING A PIPELINE OF
PROJECTS IN PROVIDING CAPACITY
FOR THIS PLANNING TO HAPPEN ON
THE GROUND --
WITH HOPES THAT WITH AN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AVAILABILITY
WE WILL BE ABLE TO SERVE MORE
NEIGHBORHOODS ACROSS THE STATE --
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THIS
THIS MORNING I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS ONCE WE GET TO
THAT POINT.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH SO
WE CAN OPEN IT UP TO TO TASK
QUESTIONS OF THE ENTIRE PANEL.
BUT THERE'S ANY MEDIA QUESTIONS
WE CAN HOLD.
ALL RIGHT WE CAN GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO DIRECTOR BELL HAN OF
FOR THE NEXT PRESENTATION.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING US THIS MORNING WE'RE
PLEASED TO BE A PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION.
AND I WON I CREDIT YOUR STAFF
FOR AN EXCELLENT STAFF REPORT
I'VE READ MY SHARE OF THEM AND
WHEN I GOT IT YESTERDAY OF
COURSE TURNED QUICKLY TO THE
ENERGY COMMISSION PORTION BUT
SPENT LAST NIGHT AFTER MY KIDS
WENT TO BED READING THE REST OF
IT AND I I LEARNED.
AN AWFUL LOT SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT --
BROADLY.
THE ENERGY COMMISSION IS TRYING
TO DO TWO THINGS THAT I THINK
ARE RELEVANT TO THE COMMITTEE'S
A FEW FEW OTHERS BUT I THINK
BROADLY.
TO AND THOSE ARE HOW DO WE MAKE
THE CLEAN ENERGY REVOLUTION
SOMETHING THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
ARE PART OF AND ENJOY THE
BENEFITS OF AND THE SECOND ONE
IS HOW ARE WE CONTRIBUTED TO
JOBS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
MAKING SURE THAT FOLKS
PARTICULARLY DISADVANTAGED.
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE OR OR
PARTICIPATE DISPENSED COMMITTEES
ARE ABLE TO GET JOBS THAT ARE A
PART OF THIS THIS CLEAN ENERGY
CHANGE WERE ALL EXPERIENCING.
SO THOSE ARE BROADLY WHAT WE'RE
AFTER WE ARE OUR FORMAL
COMMITMENT TO DIVERSITY GOES
BACK --
QUITE A NUMBER OF YEARS BUT IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN WE ADOPTED A
POLICY AT OUR OUR COMMISSIONS
ADOPTED IN IT IT TARGETS --
IT ESTABLISH A POLICY PROVIDING
FAIR AND EQUAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS TO PARTICIPATE
IN AND BENEFIT FROM.
ENERGY COMMISSION PROGRAMS WITH
A SPECIFIC FOCUS ON
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES.
FAST FOR SIX MONTHS AFTER THAT
ADOPTION IN AB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
WAS PASSED IN IT.
BASICALLY PUT IN LAW WHAT I JUST
STATED IN TERMS OF THE THE THE
TARGETS THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR WHEN HE SIGNED IT
WERE WERE AFTER.
IN WHAT WHAT --
HOW WE IMPLEMENT THIS IS WE
OPENED A PROCEEDING IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN NOT LONG AFTER THE BILL
PASSED AND WE PUT OUR PUBLIC
ADVISORS OFFICE KIND OF IN THE
DEAD THE LEAD IN CHARGE OF IT?
IN SO HISTORICALLY WE'VE HAD A
PUBLIC ADVISORS OFFICE THAT WAS
IN PLACE TO TAKE --
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY FOR
OUTRAGE TO COMMUNITIES WHERE
POWER PLANTS WERE BEING BUILT SO.
BACK TO THE ENERGY CRISIS IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES THE
LEGISLATURE SOFFIT TO CREATE AN
ENTITY THE ENERGY COMMISSION.
TO BE THE LONE ENTITY THAT DOES
ALL THE PERMITTING ASSOCIATED
WITH A POWER PLANT.
IN.
WE REALIZED THEY REALIZE BACK
THEN IT WAS IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THE PUBLIC WAS
PARTICIPATING BECAUSE TYPICALLY
LARGE INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE THAT
IS NOT.
ENTIRELY WELCOME IN ALL
COMMUNITIES SO WILL --
THAT PROCESS STARTED IN IT SINCE
THEN THE PUBLIC ADVISE ROLE IS
GROWN AND SO THAT ROLE IS NOW --
THAT THAT THE CENTER OF OUR
ACTIVITIES --
IN THIS AREA.
IN WHAT --
WE HAVE A PUBLIC ADVISER --
AND WHAT WHAT SHE DOES IN HER
TEAM DOES IS IS LARGELY OUTRAGE
SO WE TRIED IT WE TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT FOLKS KNOW ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING AND I WANT TO GET
INTO A COUPLE OF OUR MAJOR
FUNDING PROGRAMS AS YOU.
YOU JUST HEARD FROM THE WEEDS --
BUT TRY TO GET OUT THERE ON THE
FRONT END AND LET FOLKS KNOW HEY
WE'VE GOT --
A CHUNK OF FUNDING THAT MAY BE
SOMETHING YOU OR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS OR YOUR MEMBERS OF
YOUR COMMUNITY GROUPS OF
WHATEVER THE FOLKS ARE IN THIS
IS THROUGHOUT THE STATE CENTRAL
VALLEY SO THE CALIFORNIA
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA HERE.
BAY AREA --
THIS IS COMING UP IS A SOMETHING
YOU MIGHT BE INTERESTED IT'S WE
WORK HARD WITH WITH WITH MAKING
REALLY SOLID CONNECTIONS WITH
FOLKS -- AND
THEY HAD AND AND THAT'S AGAIN
THE THE POP OUR PUBLIC ADVISER
REALLY.
REALLY FOCUS ON THAT STRATEGIC
PLAN WE HAVE MEETINGS --
OF OUR LEADERSHIP TEAM THE LAST
FRIDAY OF EVERY MONTH SHE HOSTS
THOSE AND WE TALK AMONGST
OURSELVES AND SAY WHAT WE DOING
WELL WHAT WE DON'T POORLY HOW
CAN WE IMPROVE --
SO IT'S IT'S REALLY BEEN A
COMMITMENT FOR US. TO WANT TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR TWO
MAJOR PROGRAMS ONE IS CALLED
EPIC AND THE OTHER ONE IS --
IN SEARCH OF A BETTER NAME BUT
IT'S CURRENTLY CALLED THE A. R.
F. VTP THE ALTERNATIVE AND
RENEWABLE VEHICLE --
FUEL AND VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY
PROGRAM.
I WOULD HELP THE ONE EIGHTEEN
PROGRAM BECAUSE AB TEAM WAS THE
BILL THAT THAT IT'S DOLLARS PER
YEAR --
RESEARCH AND THE THE CALL THE
EIGHTY ONE EIGHTEEN PROGRAM THE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM INVEST
ABOUT A HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR IN CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS.
AND THE OUTREACH ACTIVITIES
INCLUDE IT GET MEETING WITH
COMMUNITY LEADERS PUBLIC
WORKSHOPS WECREATED EASY TO
READ MORE MULTI LINGUAL
INFORMATIONAL MATERIALS AND
WE'VE GOT A HOW TO APPLY FOR
RESEARCH FUNDING VIDEO.
AND WE BRING THESE THINGS OVER
WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO SHARE
BECAUSE SOME OF THE STUFF IS --
IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN --
AN APPLICANT --
WHICH I HAVE ON THE OTHER SIDE
TO FOR PUBLIC FUNDING IT'S NOT
ALWAYS THAT EASY TO NAVIGATE SO
THE IDEA IS TO CREATE TOOLS THAT
MAKE IT.
NOT QUITE SO DAUNTING --
THEN WE CONDUCT SURVEYS ON THE
BACK AND THE TO SEE HOW WE'RE
DOING SO GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF A
RECENT SURVEY WE DID FOR FOR
EPIC THE RESEARCH PIECE.
AND WHAT WE LEARNED IN REACHING
OUT TO FOLKS WAS THE 38% OF OUR
EPIC AGREEMENTS INCLUDE WOMEN
MINORITY DISABLED VETERAN OR
LGBT OWNED.
BUSINESSES AS HE THAT THE PRIME
OR SUBCONTRACTOR.
AND 55% OF THOSE SAME EPIC
AGREEMENTS INCLUDE A SMALL
BUSINESS OR IS A PRIME OR A
SUBCONTRACTOR.
THAT IS HOW IT ONE OTHER PROJECT
THAT IS KIND OF A DIFFERENT AREA
WERE WERE TRYING --
TO IT.
MAKE THESE --
IN ROADS INTO INTO COMMUNITIES
AND THAT IS CALLED KELSEY.
AND THAT WAS A PART OF THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM AGAIN
THIS IS RESEARCH AND WHAT IT
DOES IS PROVIDE SMALL GRANTS
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
MAX. TO TO SMALL ENTREPRENEURS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT GIVEN
MONEY THAT THAT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO COME BY AT AN EARLY
STAGE BECAUSE THE V. SEASON THE
PRIVATE EQUITIES AND AND
TRADITIONAL BANKING.
DON'T SEE THE THE VALUE IN IT
AND IT'S IT'S HIGH RISK AND WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS HIGH RISK WHEN
WE DO IT BUT WE KEEP.
THE WORD SMALL THEY DO WELL THEN
THEY CAN GET FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANTS TO REALLY
TRY TO MOVE TO THE NEXT STAGE
WITH CREDITS WHOLE ECOSYSTEM TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT. TO THIS PROGRAM
WE HAVE -- I
CAN'T TELL YOU THE NUMBERS
EXACTLY TO MORNING AND AND
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
FOLKS IS VERY EASY TO GET. TO TO
THE APPLICATION PROCESS IT'S
IT'S NOT LIKE SOME OF OUR LARGER
AWARDS WHERE THERE'S A LOT OF
LEG WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE --
IN IN IT.
THIS PARTICULAR SEE PROGRAM WE
CALL CAL SEED IS WE SET A
MINIMUM FUNDING TARGET FOR UNDER
REPRESENTED GROUPS SUCH AS
MINORITY WOMEN IN LGBT ON
BUSINESSES.
AND THAT'S THAT'S A REQUIREMENT
THAT THE THE THE FOLKS WHO
MANAGE THAT FUND LOOK FOR THOSE
LOOK FOR THOSE TARGETS.
SHIFTING TO THE AB ONE EIGHTEEN
THE TRANSPORTATION FUND --
WANT TO FOCUS ON A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON AND THE THE THE WORK
FORCE ASPECT. TO DATE WE'VE
INVESTED JUST SHY OF EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS
PROGRAM --
WITH A BROAD PORTFOLIO OF OF
ACTIVITIES WE FOUGHT WE FROM THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SO WE FUND --
USAGI WAS STAFF WE'VE GOT ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY.
ROUGHLY HALF OF THE COUNTRY'S
AVERAGE BY WAY OF COMPARISON
CHINA'S ADDING ABOUT A MILLION A
YEAR --
LATELY SO WE'RE WE'RE DOING
QUITE WELL IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE
GOT OTHERS WE CAN LOOK TO IS A
LOAD STAR FOR HOW.
TO HOW TO REALLY SUCCEED IN THIS
AREA.
SO THOUSAND PUBLIC CHARGERS
RIGHT NOW ABOUT ANOTHER AT LEAST
THAT MANY AND IN PRIVATE SHARED --
IN SITUATIONS LIKE MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING GOOGLE INTEL THESE BIG
EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FOR THEIR THEIR THEIR WORKFORCE.
AND WE'VE GOT ABOUT THIRTY NINE
HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS SO
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE IS A PART OF
WHAT WE FUND --
IN IN ADDITION WE FUND BIOFUELS
IN A WHOLE RANGE OF OTHER
ACTIVITIES BUT WITH ALL THIS
THIS -- NEW
YOU KNOW CHANGES IN THE WAY WE
VIEW OURSELVES FROM PLACE TO
PLACE WE NEED A SKILLED
WORKFORCE TO HELP BUILD THIS
BILL THESE THINGS AND WRITE THE
SOFTWARE AND ALL THE ALL THE
PARTS THAT GO WITH THAT.
SO WE'VE INVESTED OF THAT AMOUNT
I DESCRIBE THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS SO FAR INTO --
INTO THIS KIND OF TRAINING.
AND WE ARE NOT EXPERTS IN THIS
AREA SO WE RELY HEAVILY ON OUR
FRIENDS AT THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD THE EMPLOYMENT --
TRAINING PANEL THE DIVISION OF A
BRITISH SHIP STANDARDS WE WORK
AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES OTHERS TO
TRY -- TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE TARGET THE
RIGHT FOLKS WOULD WANT TO
PROVIDE TRAINING FIRST FOLKS
WERE THERE ANY JOBS IN THE BACK
AND WE WANT TO ACTUALLY GET
LOCATION RIGHT AND AND IT'S BEEN.
A GREAT NUMBER OF PARTNERSHIPS
WE'VE HAD WITH THEM TODAY WE
SINCE WE'VE TRAINED SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED FOLKS IN
THE STATE.
AT THAT TO ANSWER ME SEVEN
BUSINESSES IT'S NOT JUST
BUSINESSES AND SCHOOLS BUT TO
ANSWER THE SEVEN BUSINESSES OF
ALSO RAN --
BEEN TOUCHED ONE OF THESE WE DID
IS WE FUNDED REGIONAL ENERGY WE
CALL THEM REGIONAL INDUSTRY
CLUSTER PLANNING GRANTS SOME IN
SOME PARTS OF THE STATE --
WE WANTED TO PROVIDE FUNDING SO
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN HELP
US FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE WHERE
ARE THE FOLKS THAT WOULD BE MOST
SUITED FOR THIS WITH HER HIGH
SCHOOLS WE GO --
TO THE CURRENT WORK FORCE TO
LOOK AT OTHER LEVELS OF
EDUCATION AND AGAIN GET A LOT OF
HELP FROM FOLKS THAT DO THIS --
DO THIS EVERY DAY.
AND LASTLY I WOULD JUST MENTION
A COUPLE THINGS ONE IS --
IN ADDITION TO JUST DIRECT
WORKFORCE TRAINING WE'VE ALSO
SOME OF OUR FUNDING HAS THEN
SPURRED ADDITIONAL JOB SO ONE I
WOULD POINT TO APPROACH --
THE THE THE ECONOMICS ASSOCIATED
WITH ELECTRONIC ELECTRIC BUSES
VERSES DIESEL BUSES IS VERY
FAVORABLE SO WE'VE GOT.
THINK THREE WE GOT TO I THINK A
THIRD MAY HAVE OPENED TO BUS
MANUFACTURERS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
MANUFACTURE ELECTRIC BUSES THESE
ARE GOOD HIGH PAYING
MANUFACTURING JOBS --
AND WITH THROUGH OUR INVESTMENT
THE THE THIS PARTICULAR COMPANY
ODDS PICK ONE PRO TERRA NOW HAS
A HUNDRED EMPLOYEES A RECEIVING
UP REALLY GOOD BENEFITS LIVE AND
LET LIVE IN THE BAY AREA SO.
WORK WE'RE QUITE PROUD OF THIS
ONE I'VE GOT A LIST BUT I'LL
PRINT INTEREST FROM --
JUST MENTION THAT ONE AND I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT SAME TEAM ARE
TRANSPORTATION TEAM RECEIVED
SOME MONEY FROM PROP THIRTY NINE
SOME YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE.
INVESTED ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE ENERGY
COMMISSION TO PUT MONEY INTO
SCHOOLS TO UPGRADE LIGHTING AN
H. BACK AND CONTROLS AND THOSE
SORTS OF THINGS.
AND THERE WAS SOME MONEY LEFT
OVER AT THE END ABOUT.
A HUNDRED MILLION AND SO WE WERE
DIRECTED TO TAKE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION OF THAT AND PUT IT INTO
ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUSES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE'S WE'VE GOT
A SOLICITATION IN THE STREET TWO
OF THEM ACTUALLY ONE FOR THE
SCHOOLS ONE FOR THE BUS
MANUFACTURERS THEY WERE GONNA
TRY TO PARTNER THE TO GET A GOOD
BALK DISCOUNT DEAL ON THE ON THE
BUSES THEMSELVES.
AND THEN HAVE --
SCHOOLS APPLY FOR FUNDING IN
WERE THAT THE CRITERIA ARE
BASICALLY FORCED BUSES THE DEAN
OF THE MOST.
BOB.
POLLUTING DIESEL BUSES ARE GONNA
BE THE THE OTHER THE ONES THAT
ARE WILL BE THE THE THE THE THE
THE PRIMARY TARGETS.
SO -- THIS
IS BEEN A PROGRAM THAT --
IS SYSTEM IS ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HAVE THE JOBS
TO TO TO TO MAINTAIN THE BUSES.
BILLION INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT THEM AND AND THOSE SORTS
OF THINGS I THINK I'LL AND
THEREIN THANK YOU AGAIN.
FANTASTIC I DO ACTUALLY WANT TO
FOLLOW UP VERY QUICKLY OR
MENTION ELECTRIC BUS
MANUFACTURERS WHERE ELSE IN THE
STATE ARE THEY LOCATED.
SO THE PRO TEARS IN THE BAY AREA
I HAD THE PLEASURE OF VISITING --
B. Y. DE THE OTHER ONE I'M
CERTAIN IS IN CALIFORNIA THERE
IN -- IT'LL
A VALLEY OF LANCASTER.
CALIFORNIA SO IT'S ABOUT.
HOUR AND A HALF NORTH OF LOS
ANGELES NORTHWEST.
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
AT THIS MOMENT.
UNDER FOR SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND
CONTINUE WITH THAT THIS PIANO
AND WE'D LOVE TO GO AHEAD AND
CONTINUE WITH.
OUR DIRECTOR [inaudible]
DOCTOR BERMAN.
DIRECT YOUR BERMAN EXCUSE ME
THANK YOU THE OF GOOD MORNING
MISS CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS LAURIE BERMAN I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF CALTRANS AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY ABOUT HOW IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LEGISLATURE
CALTRANS CAN PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
FROM HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
OUR GREATEST OPPORTUNITY TODAY
COMES FROM THE PASSAGE OF THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ROAD REPAIR AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT ALSO KNOWN AS
SB ONE WHICH PROVIDES AN
ESTIMATED INCREASE OF FIFTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING.
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
CALTRANS HAS COMPLETED NINETY
PROJECTS SINCE THE ENACTMENT OF
THIS BILL AND WE HAVE MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED MORE PROJECTS THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT I'LL GET
OUT TO CONSTRUCTION --
WE'RE NOT JUST IMPROVING
PAVEMENT AND BRIDGES WE ARE ALSO
IMPROVING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE.
I WILL DESCRIBE MORE ABOUT OUR
NEW OUT REACH PLAN THAT WE
DELIVER TO THE LEGISLATURE.
THIS YEAR IS A PART OF SB ONE OH
THREE A BUDGET TRAILER BILL TO
SB ONE THE FIRST I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE GREAT
THINGS THAT CALTRANS HAS DONE.
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES INCLUDING
THOSE OWNED BY WOMEN PEOPLE OF
COLOR DISABLED VETERANS LGBT Q.
INDIVIDUALS AND OTHER
HISTORICALLY UNDER REPRESENTED
GROUPS.
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS
CALTRANS HAS AWARDED MORE THAN
THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN CONTRACTS AND
PROCUREMENTS TO CERTIFIED SMALL
BUSINESSES INCLUDING MANY
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES AND DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE FIRMS.
OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS
CALTRANS HAS PARTICIPATED IN
NEARLY EIGHT HUNDRED PRE BID AND
PRE PROPOSAL MEETINGS TRAININGS
WORKSHOPS AND BUSINESS MATCH
MAKING EVENT.
THE STATE WIDE EVENTS ASSIST
SMALL BUSINESSES COMPETING FOR
CALTRANS CONTRACTS AND
PROCUREMENTS.
AND WE WOULD.
GIVE ME WE INVITE YOU TO PARTNER
WITH A IN FORUMS TO INCREASE
TRAINING AND OUTREACH FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
CALTRANS CONTINUES TO HOST
STATEWIDE AND REGIONAL SMALL
BUSINESS COUNCILS WITH DIVERSE
MEMBERSHIPS REPRESENTING MULTI
CULTURAL AND MULTI ETHNIC TRADE
ORGANIZATIONS CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE AND OTHER GROUPS.
THESE COUNCILS ENCOURAGE SMALL
BUSINESS PARTICIPATION ON
CALTRANS CONTRACTS AND PROVIDE
VALUABLE FORMS FOR US TO OBTAIN
FEEDBACK ABOUT OUR POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES AFFECTING SMALL
BUSINESS.
SINCE JANUARY OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WE HAVE PLACED ADVERTISEMENTS IN
SEVEN LANGUAGES IN OVER SEVENTY
FIVE PUBLICATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO CALL ATTENTION TO OUR
UPCOMING CONTRACTING
OPPORTUNITIES.
AND TRAINING AND OUTREACH EVENTS.
WE WILL DEBUT A CONTRACTOR BOOT
CAMP IN STOCKTON LATER THIS WEEK
AND IN LOS ANGELES IN MAY TO
TRAIN CONTRACTORS ON HOW TO DO
BUSINESS WITH CALTRANS.
NEXT MONTH WE PLAN TO HOST
STATEWIDE MEET THE PRIMES AND
MEET THE BUYERS ADVANCE TO
INTRODUCE NEW AND LIVING A
CONTRACTING SMALL BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES. TO PRIME
CONTRACTORS INTO CALTRANS
CONTRACT MANAGERS AND BUYERS.
AND WE INVITE YOU TO PARTNER
WITH US IN EXPANDING THESE
ENDEAVORS AND THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT THEY PROVIDE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
CALTRANS IS COMMITTED TO
FOSTERING A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
FOR ALL SMALL BUSINESSES
COMPETING FOR CONTRACTING AND
PROCUREMENT OPPORTUNITIES.
INCLUDING BUSINESSES OWNED BY
UNDER REPRESENTED INDIVIDUALS.
STATE LAW SETS A GOAL FOR
CALTRANS TO AWARD 25% OF STATE
FUNDED CONTRACTS AND
PROCUREMENTS TO SMALL BUSINESS
WE CLEARLY EXCEEDED THIS GOAL
LAST QUARTER WITH A SMALL
BUSINESS PARTICIPATION RATE OF
THIRTY FOUR POINT 3%.
STATE LAW ALSO SETS A GOAL FOR
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE PARTICIPATION OF 3%
OF STATE FUNDED CONTRACTS AND
PROCUREMENTS.
LAST QUARTER WE ALSO EXCEEDED
THIS GOAL WITH A PARTICIPATION
RATE OF THREE POINT 4%.
I'M EXCITED TO SHARE THAT WE
HAVE ALSO SUCCESSFULLY EXCEEDED
BOTH OF THESE GOALS IN EACH OF
THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
EVEN WITH THE ADDITIONAL INFLUX
OF SB.
ONE STARTING THIS YEAR OUR GOAL
IS TO AWARD SEVENTEEN POINT 6%
OF CONTRACTS.
FUNDED THROUGH THE FEDERAL
HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION TO
CERTIFIED DISADVANTAGED BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES THIS GOAL WAS SET TO
A DISPARITY STUDY OF OUR FEDERAL
HIGHWAY PROGRAM.
SO FAR IN THIS FEDERAL FISCAL
YEAR WE HAVE ATTAINED A
PARTICIPATION RATE OF SEVENTEEN
POINT 26%.
THIS IS INCREDIBLE GROWTH FROM
PREVIOUS YEARS WHEN OUR
DISPARITY SET THE GOAL AT TWELVE
AND A HALF PERCENT.
CALTRANS IS ALSO CURRENTLY
CONDUCTING A DISPARITY STUDY FOR
CONTRACTS FUNDED BY THE FEDERAL
TRANSIT ADMINISTRATION.
WITH SO MUCH WORK TO BE DONE DUE
TO SB ONE WE NEED TO FOSTER
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT AND
WE NEED TO GROWTH.
GIVES ME THE CONTRACT WORKFORCE
TO DO THIS WE ARE PARTNERING
WITH A WIDE VARIETY OF AGENCIES
AND INSTITUTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE INCLUDING THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS. TO
PROVIDE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR UNDERSERVED
INDIVIDUALS.
IN NORTHERN AND CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE CONTRACTED
DIRECTLY WITH THE FIELD
IRONWORKERS APPRENTICESHIP AND
TRAINING PROGRAM TO RECRUIT
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE
ENGAGED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY LOS ANGELES
THANK YOU.
AND LONG BEACH CITY COLLEGE TO
OFFER A LETTERS OF OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAM THESE PROGRAMS INCREASE
THE PARTICIPATION OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR WOMEN IN OTHER
DISADVANTAGED INDIVIDUALS IN THE
HIGHWAY CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
AND PROVIDES PRE APPRENTICESHIP
TRAINING.
CALTRANS IS ALSO WORKED WITH THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES. TO CREATE
THE SECOND CHANCE PROGRAM.
THIS PROVIDES ON THE JOB
TRAINING OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD FOR OVER FOUR HUNDRED
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED. TWENTY OF THESE
PARTICIPANTS HAVE BEEN HIRED AS
PERMANENT CALTRANS EMPLOYEES AND
65% OF THE REMAINING
PARTICIPANTS SECURE GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT FOLLOWING THE PROGRAM.
CALTRANS HAS ALSO PARTNERED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
THE BUTTE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
AND THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES TO
PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT. TO THE
PAROLE THE WORK PROGRAM.
WE HAVE FIFTY FOUR CREWS ACROSS
THE STATE WAS SIX TO EIGHT
PEOPLE PER CREW.
CALTRANS HAS HIRED MORE THAN
SEVENTY PERMANENT EMPLOYEES FROM
THIS PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM ALSO BENEFITS ARE
COMMUNITIES FOR EXAMPLE AT THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY CALTRANS
PAROLE THE PROGRAM HAS A 9%
RECIDIVISM RATE.
COMPARED TO THE 52% RECIDIVISM
RATE FOR THOSE WHO DID NOT
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION TO THESE EFFORTS SB
ONE OH THREE REQUIRES CALTRANS
TO FOCUS ITS OUTREACH EFFORTS ON
INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES FOR NEW
AND LIMITED CONTRACTING.
SMALL BUSINESS ENTERPRISES
CALTRANS SMALL BUSINESS OUT
REACH PLAN DESCRIBES HOW THE
DEPARTMENT WILL IMPLEMENT THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE LAW.
AND INCREASE PROCUREMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE SMALL
BUSINESSES INCLUDING THOSE OWNED
BY DISADVANTAGED GROUPS.
CALTRANS IS WORKING TO
INCORPORATE ELEMENTS OF THE
OUTRAGE PLAN INTO OUR POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES TO PROMOTE
AWARENESS OF CONTRACTING AND
PROCUREMENT OPPORTUNITIES.
AND INCREASE THE PARTICIPATION
OF NEW AND LIMITING CONTRACTING
SMALL BUSINESS ENTERPRISES.
CALTRANS IS ALSO WORKING TO
IMPROVE INTERNAL DATA MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS AND PROCESSES TO
EFFECTIVELY MONITOR
PARTICIPATION.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO PARTNERING
WITH YOU ON THESE EFFORTS AND
WE'LL KEEP YOU UPDATED IN OUR
FUTURE REPORTS TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THE
OPPORTUNITY SPEAKER TODAY AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU AYE AYE IT'S
VERY EXCITING TO HAVE EACH OF
YOU HERE TODAY --
THE DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS SAID
THE COMMISSION'S ORGANIZATION
JUST TO TOUCH ON THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE EXISTING AND HOW.
FOLKS HAVE TAPPED INTO THOSE
EXIST I HAD A QUESTION REGARDING
II GOVERNMENT PLATFORMS --
JUST TECHNO TECHNOLOGY
ASSISTANCE AND THIS GIVEN AGE
YOU KNOW HOW ARE WE REALLY.
ADDRESSING THIS WITHIN EACH OF
YOUR DEPARTMENTS.
ARE HOW OUR FOLKS ACCESSING YOUR
PROGRAMS.
THROUGH THOSE VARIOUS METHODS.
AND MAYBE COULD ALSO TOUCH ON
INITIATIVES.
FOR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN SO
SPECIFICALLY AS IT RELATES.
TO IF GOVERNMENT CORRECT.
I MEAN WE DO A LOT OF WORK
OVERALL JUST IN TERMS OF SORT OF
DOING DIRECT OUTREACH TO
COMMUNITIES WORK SHOPPING WITH
COMMUNITY SINCE WE MANY OUR
APPLICANTS TEND TO BE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ARE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS --
SO WE SPEND A FAIR AMOUNT OF
TIME ACTUALLY OUT IN COMMUNITIES
WORKING ONE ON ONE TO TALK
THROUGH.
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND
OPPORTUNITIES --
WE DO NOT HAVE A SINGLE PLATFORM
THAT WE USE FOR ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS --
BUT WE JUST WE DO HAVE A VERY
ROBUST ADAM OUT REACH AND
NETWORK OF OUTREACH AND
TECHNICAL APPLICANTS.
IS -- MAYBE
YOU COULD ALSO TOUCH ON ARE
THERE ANY.
SMARTER REGULATIONS TO REDUCE
IMPEDIMENTS TO ACCESSING THESE
PROGRAMS.
I MEAN I THINK IT WAS MENTIONED
IT OFTEN THESE PROGRAMS ARE --
ARE CHALLENGING IN TERMS AS AT
ONE THING THAT IS NICE ABOUT
THAT THAT TRANSFORMED OF CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM IS IT
PROVIDES A WAY. FOR A COMMUNITY
TO ACCESS FUNDS FOR MULTIPLE
TYPES OF PROJECTS SO RIGHT NOW
OTHERWISE YOU WOULD GO TO A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
THROUGH THE TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
THROUGH A SINGLE APPLICATION YOU
CAN ACCESS A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
PROJECTS TYPES --
I THINK WHAT WE HAVE FOUND
ESPECIALLY WITH --
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ARE
UNDER RESOURCE COMMUNITIES IS
REALLY DOING THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE --
AND WE'VE WORKED WITH OTHER
DEPARTMENTS TO DO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THEIR PROGRAMS AS
WELL.
HAS A LOT OF BENEFIT AND WE'VE
SEEN IT --
WORK IN A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
WAYS WILL DO DIRECT APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE WORK WITH FOLKS A WE
ALSO WILL WORK TO TRAIN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
BE A RESOURCE ON THE GROUND FOR
DIFFERENTPROGRAMS --
AND SO WE'VE SEEN REACHING UNDER
RESOURCE COMMUNITIES DOING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
CAPACITY BUILDING --
IS IS BEEN EXT REALLY SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE THAT IS OFTEN A BIG NEED --
AND AND LIKE I SAID THERE'S A
NUMBER OF MODELS FOR HOW TO DO
THAT.
AND I THINK YOU'RE SEEING
INCREASING USE OF TECHNO Và OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE MODELS BUT
HAS BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE.
PLEASE TO HEAR.
SO I WOULD JUST AT ABOUT SIX
YEARS AGO WE CREATED AN E.
FILING SYSTEM SO IT USED TO BE
THAT WE GET LITERALLY BANKERS
BOXES FULL OF APPLICATIONS
BECAUSE WOULD REQUIRE THAT THAT
YOU PROVIDE TEN COPIES OF THAT
OUR SCORING TEAM WITH EACH OF A
COPY.
AND WE GOT A FEW COMPLAINTS AND
WE YOU KNOW PEOPLE SAY YOU KNOW
IT'S A COST ME A THOUSAND
DOLLARS JUST TO PRINT MAIL THE
STUFF TO YOU GUYS VERSUS HITTING
SEND WITH --
PDF SO WE CHANGED AND NOW FOLKS
CAN OF APPLY ELECTRONICALLY.
FUNDAMENTAL AND THAT'S HELPED A
LOT BUT FUNDAMENTALLY IT DOESN'T
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OF OUR STUFF
IS COMPLICATED SO IF YOU WANT TO
APPLY FOR A RESEARCH GRANT OR
EVEN SOME OF THE APPLICATION --
WORK WE'RE DOING WHERE YOU KNOW
YOU WANT TO TEST SOMETHING OUT
YOU YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE A REALLY
HIGH DEGREE OF SOPHISTICATION SO
WHAT WE'VE TRIED TO DO THERE IS
MUCH MORE.
IN A BOWL SCHOOL FOR LACK OF
BETTER TERM GOING OUT MEET WITH
FOLKS SHAKING HANDS --
IN FINDING PARTNERS WE CAN HELP
THEM TRYING TO PAIR THEM SO WE
CREATED SOMETHING THAT ALLOWS
FOLKS TO THE LITTLE COMMUNITY
THIS CREATED TO WORK WITH ONE
ANOTHER AND SO.
YOU MAY BE REALLY GOOD AT THIS
BUT YOU'RE NOT VERY GOOD AT THAT
BUT TO REALLY SUBMIT A PACKAGE
IT'S GOT A CHANCE OF WINNING IN
THE BOWL THREE AND MANY MORE.
THAT'S PART OF IT WE'VE ALSO GOT
A COMMUNITY AND I'M SURE EACH OF
MY COLLEAGUES DO AS WELL OF OF
FOLKS WHO WILL ASSIST I WILL
WRITE YOUR GRANT FOR YOU AND
I'LL HELP YOU NAVIGATE THIS
PROCESS IN EXCHANGE FOR A FEE
YEAR.
HOWEVER THAT WORKS SO TRY TO
MAKE THOSE PARTNERSHIPS AS WELL --
BUT ON THE YOU KNOW THE
FUNDAMENTAL CHALLENGE OF OUR
GREAT BE COMPLICATED WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO LISTEN.
BUT IT'S MOST OF AN ABOUT
PARTNERSHIPS.
SO IN THE AREA OF SMALL BUSINESS
WE HAVE A LOT OF INFORMATION ON
OUR WEBSITE AND WE ALSO HAVE
SMALL BUSINESS COUNCILS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AS WELL AS
ONE STATEWIDE SMALL BUSINESS
COUNCIL AND SO.
WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT THAT
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHERE THEY CAN
LOOK TO FIND OUT UPCOMING DID SO
WE POST ALL OF THE ARE PROJECTS
THAT WILL BE OUT FOR BID.
SO PEOPLE CAN FIND THAT
INFORMATION ONLINE AND WE ALSO
HAVE TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES SUCH
AS THE CONTRACTORS BOOT CAMP.
AND THEN --
ANOTHER THING THAT'S MORE RECENT
WE HAVE CALTRANS HAS TWELVE
DISTRICTS AROUND THE STATE EACH
DISTRICT.
AS A RESULT OF SB ONE AS WELL AS
OUR ASSET MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
EACH JUST FULLY --
OF PROJECTS GENERALLY THERE'S
GONNA BE SOME CHANGES OVER THE
NEXT TEN YEARS BUT CONTRACTORS
AND SUBCONTRACTORS CAN LOOK AT
THAT AND GET A SENSE OF WHERE
THE WORK IS GOING TO BE AND WHAT
TYPE OF WORK IT'LL BE OVER THE
NEXT TEN YEARS.
AND I THINK --
THAT'S GOING TO BE A GOOD
RESOURCES BOTH FOR PRIME
CONTRACTORS AND FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT.
IS THE STATE.
THE RIGHT PLACE FOR ME TO TO
INVEST MY TIME INTO LEARNING HOW
TO DO BUSINESS.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR BERMAN.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER REAVIS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS --
I'VE HAD SOME DIRECT EXPERIENCE
WITH -- TWO
OF YOU AT LEAST IN YOUR PROGRAMS --
OF COURSE THE TCC PROGRAM WAS
VERY EXCITED THIS DECEMBER THAT
PACOIMA WAS ONE OF THE AWARD
AWARDED THAT.
YOU KNOW THE GRANT --
THEY'RE VERY EXCITED AND I THINK
IT'S A TRUE --
EXAMPLE OF A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION THAT KNOWS THE
COMMUNITY WAS ABLE TO IDENTIFY
THE NEIGHBORHOOD NEEDS --
BEING PART OF THIS PROCESS VERY
EXCITED IF THERE'S ANYTHING I
CAN DO TO HELP AND SUPPORT I
WILL BE THERE --
AND I'M SURE THAT I HOPE YOU
CONTINUE TO AWARD A MORE OF
THESE --
GRANTS TO OTHER NEIGHBORHOODS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AROUND
THE STATE --
BECAUSE I THINK WE COULD LEARN
FROM THESE PROJECTS RIGHT YEAH
I'M SURE YOU'RE GONNA LEARN.
AND BE ABLE TO EXPAND THIS
PROGRAM STATEWIDE --
AND DIRECTOR BERMAN YOU KNOW
I'VE --
WORKED WITH --
CALTRANS DISTRICT SEVEN THE ME
ESPECIALLY THE MAINTENANCE
DIVISION IN MY AREA --
THEY'VE BEEN GREAT NOT JUST AT
YOU KNOW SOLVING SOME ISSUES IN
OUR AREA --
BUT OF WE'VE ALSO TALKED ABOUT
YOU KNOW WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
IN OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
MAINTENANCE DIVISION I KNOW --
THE DIRECTOR THERE THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR HAD MENTIONED TO ME
THAT THEY WERE HAVING.
A PROBLEMS FINDING PEOPLE IN MY
AREA TO WORK IN THE MAINTENANCE
DIVISION AND I DEFINITELY WANT
TO PARTNER TO OFFER SOME TYPE OF
WORKSHOP OR YOU KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY
JOBS AND I THINK WORKING FOR YOU
IN THE MAINTENANCE DIVISION.
IN THEIR OWNCOMMUNITY --
IS IS PERFECT AND THAT'S
SOMETHING I DEFINITELY WANT TO
DO THIS YEAR --
SO THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING.
ALL OF YOUR PROGRAMS BUT I'M
PARTICULARLY OF COURSE
INTERESTED IN.
BOB YOU KNOW RECRUITING WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITY TO WORK.
IN THE COMMUNITY THAT WOULD BE
GREAT AND CALTRANS IS STILL
HIRING WELL YEAH TO TALK OKAY
SURE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST A ON
THE PRESENTATION YOU MENTIONED
THAT THE TOP 5% OF DISADVANTAGE --
COMMUNITIES KNOWS BASED ON SOME
TYPE OF DEFINITION OR SOME TYPE
OF SCALE SO HOW WOULD I GET THAT
LIST OF THOSE TO SPENT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
YES SO -- WE
USE --
CALLIN VIRUS SCREEN WHICH IS THE
TOOL DEVELOPED --
BY THE OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH HAZARD ASSESSMENT WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY --
TO DEFINE DISADVANTAGE CAM.
A TOOL THAT LOOKS AT A SUITE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL BURDENS SO
POLLUTION AND THEN SOCIO
ECONOMIC FACTORS AS WELL --
IT TO DEFINE THOSE COMMUNITIES I
WE CAN CERTAINLY PROVIDE YOU
WITH A LIST --
THAT IN THAT SHOWS THE TOP 5% OF
THAT SCORE THE HIGHEST ON THAT --
AND THEN FOR OUR PROGRAM AT
LEAST HALF OF THE PROJECT AREA
NEEDS TO SIT WITH IN.
THAT TOP 5% AREA.
THANK YOU.
AND THEN I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
RECIDIVISM RATE --
WITH THE PROGRAM THAT'S BEING
DONE I THINK IT CURRENTLY IN
VALLEY.
COUNTY IS THERE A WAY THAT WE
COULD.
LOOK AT EXPANDING THAT MODEL
INTO OTHER AREAS OR IS IT
ALREADY SOMETHING THAT'S BEING
EXPLORED WE CONTINUE TO EXPECT
TO EXPAND IT AND IT'S WE HAVE IT
IN LA SACRAMENTO SANDIA GRAHAM.
SO WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
SURE FOLKS KNOW THAT THAT'S AN
OPTION ON ON WAY TO ENHANCE OUR
MAINTENANCE WORK FORCE.
SURE HOW WE DO A BETTER JOB AT
IN IN OUR DISTRICT AND THEN THE
INLAND EMPIRE AREA OF BRINGING
THOSE TYPES OF PROGRAMS UP.
AS FAR AS CUTTING ON THE
RECIDIVISM RATE THAT'S GOING ON
LET ME CHECK.
WITH THAT DISTRICT AND SEE IF
WE'RE ALREADY USING IT AND AND
I'LL LET YOU KNOW IF WE'RE NOT
WE CAN TALK ABOUT ADDING THAT TO
THE INLAND EMPIRE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MANAGER.
DIRECTOR BROWN HAD I HAD A QUICK
FOLLOW UP QUESTION OR IF YOU CAN
ACTUALLY HIGHLIGHT AGAIN AND THE
NUMBERS IS RELEASED HIS ABS ON
THE ROAD TO DAY AND THE CHARGING
STATIONS.
THOSE NUMBERS CERTAINLY SO --
THAT I CHECKED THIS MORNING
THERE'S A SITE CALLED THERE'S A
NONPROFIT CALLED THE LOWS OF THE
LOC.
IT'S SORT OF A STATE PRIVATE
HYBRID AND THEY REPORT THE
NUMBERS REGULARLY AND SO AS OF
THIS MORNING IT WAS.
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY SIX THOUSAND
JOBS THEIR EMISSION VEHICLES --
JUST SHY OF TWENTY THOUSAND
PUBLIC CHARGERS SO THAT'S ONES
ANYONE IN THE ROOM HERE TO DRIVE
UP TO AN ACCESS.
AGAIN THERE'S MANY MORE THAT ARE
THAT ARE PRIVATE PEOPLE HAVE MET
THEIR HOMES BUT THERE'S TWENTY
THOUSAND PUBLIC WAS WE FUNDED
THE ENERGY COMMISSION ROUGHLY
HALF OF THOSE.
AND THIRTY NINE HYDROGEN
STATIONS ICAL SEPARATE DOESN'T
HUNDRED VEHICLE SO SMALL BUT THE
FUTURE THE TRAJECTORIES GROWING
AND PROMISING.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY THE
CHALLENGES TO GET MORE IS ABS ON
THE ROAD [inaudible]
MOVING FORWARD.
WELL IT'S A BIT OF A CHICKEN AND
EGG PROBLEM --
RIGHT.
YOU'VE GOT THE PEOPLE ACCUSTOMED
TO THE CONVENTIONAL WAY OF
FUELING THEIR VEHICLES AND SEE
GETTING PEOPLE TO CHANGE ONE OF
ONE OF THE BIGGEST THINGS
FOLLOWS LEARNED WAS --
I I DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT
STATISTIC BUT A STAGGERING
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHEN YOU ASK
THEM ABOUT ELECTRIC OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLE SAY.
WHAT?
I MEAN THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY
ARE THEY DON'T KNOW THAT THEY
EXIST SO IT'S AWFUL HARD TO
PERSUADE SOMEONE THAT THIS MIGHT
BE A GOOD IDEA GOOD VALUE FOR
THEIR FAMILY --
THE WAY TO SAVE FUNDS IF THEY
DON'T REALLY EVEN KNOW WHAT THEY
ARE SO LOTS OF CHALLENGES BUT
OUR ROLE IS REALLY TO FOCUS
MAINLY ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE SO
THAT FOLKS DON'T HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION OF DO I REALLY WANT
SOMETHING WHERE IT'S GONNA BE
VERY DIFFICULT.
TO FUEL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I DO I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT --
SOMETHING WITH THAT I CALTRANS I
KNOW THAT THERE WAS CHIU JOB
FAIRS AND SAMBAR DINO COUNTY --
AND WOULD LOVE TO ENCOURAGE YOU
TO ALSO LOOK AT ARAB RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AS WELL YOU KNOW AS IT.
I KNOW WE HAVE MANY SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS ON THIS
COMMITTEE BUT YOU DON'T REALLY
LOOKING AT WAYS WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER IN PARTNER.
I BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS BUT
JUST WANT I THINK --
ALL YOUR STAFF FOR THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING ACROSS THE STATE
YEAH IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE
WORKING WITH THEM ON THE
PROJECTS WITHIN MY DISTRICT AND
WITHIN THE COUNTY OF RIVERSIDE.
I YOU KNOW AT THIS TIME I KNOW
ALL OF THE QUESTIONS ARE FOR
EACH OF YOU BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INSIGHTS --
FOR THE PROGRAMS THAT YOU
ADMINISTER --
THE FUNDS THAT YOU PROVIDE TOO
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES --
THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES OFTENTIMES --
YOU KNOW THOSE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ARE SO IMPORTANT TO
THANK YOU FOR REACHING OUT AND
DOING THAT.
THE ONE ON ONE AS NEEDED --
AT ANY CLOSING COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
WONDERFUL WHAT THANK YOU TO EACH
OF YOU.
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO NOW OPENED THE
PORTION OF THIS HEARING TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS FOR THOSE WHO
WOULD PREFER TO OFFER IN
COMMENTS YOU'RE ABLE TO DO SO
UNTIL APRIL FIFTEENTH AND SUBMIT
THOSE TO THE JOBS COMMITTEE.
I WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST A EACH
PUBLIC COMMENT BE LIMITED TO
THREE MINUTES.
MORE EXTENDED TIME CAN BE
OFFERED --
IN WRITING.
IS THERE SIGN UP SHEETS
.
THE FIRST I HAVE ON THE SIGN UP
SHE IS DAVID NELSON.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR CERVANTES IN
A MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DAVID
HEAR BACK FROM LAST WEEK WITH
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTERS I'M
REALLY HAPPY THAT.
MARQUISE JACKSON REPRESENTS
KINGS AND SAN DIEGO NETWORK
PATTON I REPRESENT LOS ANGELES
AND KURT CLARKE REPRESENTING
CENTER CALIFORNIA ARE HERE TODAY.
AND REALLY GREAT HEARING I JUST
WANTED -- TO
YOU KNOW I'M VERY INTRIGUED
ABOUT GREEN MORE.
AND FOR THE SPDC AS A REMINDER
YES --
CALIFORNIA'S FIVE REGIONS --
FOR FOR THE SPDC AND SO CONSIDER
US -- A
RESOURCE PARTNER AS YOU LOOK TO
SEE HOW AN INCREASE HOUSE SMALL
BUSINESS IS A PART OF THE
INCLUSIVE ECONOMY THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
AND I ALSO THINK THAT SMALL
BUSINESS IS THE KEY SPOKEN TO
THE WHEEL THAT WE'RE CREATING --
FOR AN INCLUSIVE ECONOMY JUST
REALLY QUICKLY FOR LAST YEAR'S
ECONOMIC IMPACT FOR THE SB DC'S --
WE WERE PART OF CREATING OVER
NINE THOUSAND JOBS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FOURTEEN HUNDRED
BUSINESSES.
AND FOR THIS COMMITTEE ALONE.
ABOUT FORTY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION IN NEW TAXABLE REVENUES
IN YOUR DISTRICTS WAS TOUCHED BY --
THE SPDC AND SO WE'RE EXCITED TO
BE A PART OF THE CONVERSATION
AND ADDING VALUE DON'T WANT WHAT
YOU'RE DOING --
BUT ALSO MAKING SURE THAT SOME.
THE ONE WITHOUT FORCE AND INTO
THE JOB CREATING FORCE WHICH IS
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT SO
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING PAT FROM KUSHIDA I
AM PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE.
LARGEST ETHNIC CHAMBER IN THE
REGION WE REPRESENT THE
INTERESTS OF OVER.
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND API
BUSINESSES HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I AM THE OLDEST LIVING
CHAMBER EXECUTIVE EVER IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS WORKING WITH.
MANY OF THE ENTITIES THAT WERE A
PRETTY DAY AND I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT THE CHALLENGES ARE ENEMY
VERY SUCCINCT ABOUT THIS.
SO THEY TALKED ABOUT AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE --
MADAM CHAIR YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT
HOW THEY CAN ACTUALLY USE
TECHNOLOGY TO START TO DO BETTER --
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION AROUND
WHAT OPPORTUNITY IS OF A BILL
WITH THEM.
AND I DIDN'T SAY THEY DANCED
AROUND THAT BUT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE SOLUTIONS YET SO AS AN
EXAMPLE WE PARTNERED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM.
A HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN COLLEGES
WE CREATED A PLATFORM CALLED
CONTRACT READINESS AND CONTRACT
RAINY IS IS BASICALLY AN ONLINE
PLATFORM WE CAN GO GET A
CERTIFICATE áP TV.
AFTER YOU'VE --
TAKEN THE COURT INDUCTION TO
CERTIFICATION BECAUSE MANY OF
OUR PARTICULAR MINORITY FIRMS.
DON'T EVEN KNOW WITH THE FRONT
DOOR IS AND SO I I SIT ON ALL
THE COUNCIL'S THEY TALKED ABOUT
ICE ON THE DIVERSITY COUNCIL FOR
THE PUBLIC UTILITY COMMISSION
LISTEN ON CALTRANS.
ICE NINETY GS.
I SALUTE ALL OF THEM RIGHT THE
PROBLEM IS IS THAT THOSE FRONT
DOORS A VERY DIFFICULT TO WALK
THROUGH.
SO INTENTIONAL STRATEGIES ABOUT
WE HOW WE CREATE PATHWAYS FOR
THOSE FRONT DOORS TO BE OPENED
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE.
AS AN AS MEANINGFUL AS A
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM I THINK
WOULD GO FAR RIGHT BECAUSE
THAT'S AN INTRODUCTION RIGHT.
SO YOU'VE GOT TO ONE COMPANIES
THAT HAVE NO IDEA WHAT YOU'RE
THREE DEPEND HOW YOU LOOK AT IT
HAVE NO IDEA HOW TO EVEN GET
THEIR FOOT IN THE DOOR.
THEN YOU'VE GOT COMPANIES THAT
ACTUALLY GROWN TO THE SYSTEM AND
THEY'RE STILL NOT ABLE TO BECOME
A PRIME.
RIGHT AND THERE'S A LOT OF AREAS
AROUND THAT I LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
TALK TO US ABOUT THAT BUT I JUST
WANT TO SAY REALLY REALLY
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION WE HAD
HERE TODAY AND I LOOK REALLY FOR
TO WORK WITH ALL OF YOU THANK
YOU.
IN JUST A MINUTE WILL BE A GOOD
MORNING SURE ARE CERVANTES AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MARK HE'S JACKSON ON THE CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA.
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER LEADERSHIP COUNCIL WHICH
IS THE SPDC SOMEWHERE REPEAT A
LITTLE BIT OF A ABOUT WHAT DAVIS
SAID THE FIRST ALL.
START WITH THIS SO LAST YEAR THE
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER RECEIVE HISTORIC FUNDING
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
EXPANSION PROGRAM.
WHICH HAS ALLOWED US TO EXPAND
OUR SERVICES AND PROVIDE HELP
AND ASSISTANCE TO DIFFERENT
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS THAT ARE FUN
FROM LIMITED US TO SERVE IN THE
PAST.
AND DIFFERENT POPULATIONS --
OF PEOPLE LEARNING FROM THAT
EXPANSION --
THANKS TO THE FUNDS THAT WERE
RECEIVING SO --
I WANT TO BE A TOP PARTNER OF TO
THE JEDI COMMITTEE AND ALSO THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WEATHER IS --
LET YOU ALL KNOW WHAT WE LEARNED
FROM PROVIDING THE SERVICES OR
BRING IN BUSINESSES THAT ARE IN
YOUR DISTRICT TO TALK WITH YOU
ALL ABOUT THINGS THAT THEY ARE
SEEING AND CHALLENGES THAT THEY
NEED TO OVERCOME --
THANKS AGAIN FOR ALL THE FUNDING
THAT THAT YOU ALL VOTED --
FOR AND IF THERE'S EVER
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
DIRECTLY ADDRESS THAT YOU SEE IS
A ECONOMIC CONCERN --
PLEASE LET US KNOW AND WILL JUMP
RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO WE WERE HERE
LAURIE CAMBER SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA ALSO REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS SACRAMENTO
VALLEY.
AND ALSO OPPORTUNITY FUND WHICH
IS A SMALL BUSINESS LENDING OUR
COMPANY AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND AND OUR CHIEF
CONSULTANT.
OF FOR PUTTING THIS HEARING
TOGETHER TODAY --
IT WAS SUCH A PLEASURE TO HEAR
OUR NEW DIRECTOR OF COPAYS TALK
ABOUT HIS PLANS AND WHAT HE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE --
IN YOU KNOW MOVING CALIFORNIA
FORWARD AND WE LOOK FORWARD AS
SMALL BUSINESS CAL WITH YOU
WORKING WITH COPAYS --
WE ARE PARTNER ARE ON A LOT OF
PROJECTS WITH GOBIZ WE SUPPORT
THEM WE SUPPORTED THEM I AM
GETTING INCREASED FUNDING WE
SUPPORT THERE ARE.
PROGRAMS THAT THEY HELP --
SMALL BUSINESSES SO --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AS THE SAYS SESSION MOVES ON
THANK YOU.
THE CHAIR CERVANTES A AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JIM
HOLLY I'M WITH LAWRENCE BERKELEY
NATIONAL LABORATORY --
AS YOU THINK ABOUT HOW TO BUILD
A DIVERSE INCLUSIVE ECONOMY THAT
WORKS FOR EVERYBODY WOULD LOVE
TO BE A RESOURCE TO YOU --
LAWRENCE BERKLEY LAB IS ONE OF
THE SEVENTEEN DOE LABS WERE THE
ONLY ONE THAT'S MANAGED
EXCLUSIVELY BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE KNOWN FOR OUR
EXPERTISE IN ENERGY EFFICIENCY
CLEAN ENERGY WATER --
PURIFICATION AND TREATMENT --
IN A NUMBER OF OTHER AREAS.
I JUST WANT TO SAY VERY QUICKLY --
FIRST OF ALL WE WORK THE
STRATEGIC SEARCH WE'VE DONE HAS.
OF EITHER I REALLY DETECTED A
SIGNIFICANT SHIFT ON THEIR PART
IN RECENT YEARS. TO WORK WITH
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES --
ONE OF OUR MOST RECENT GRANTS
WITH THE GROWTH COUNSEL FOR
EXAMPLE INVOLVES WORKING FRESNO
HELPING THAT CAN MAKE A DEAL --
DEVELOPER A RESILIENCE STRATEGY
IN THE FACE OF CLIMATE CHANGE --
TO HELP LOWEST THE MOST JUST
DISADVANTAGED MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS DEAL WITH EXTREME
HEAT -- BUT
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF OTHER TOOLS
I WANTED TO BRING TO YOUR
ATTENTION ONE IS WHAT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER AS CAL SEAT
AND CYCLOTRON ROAD.
IS A PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE
CREATED THAT ESSENTIALLY ALLOWS
YOUNG ENTREPRENEURS TO TACKLE
VERY DIFFICULT PROBLEMS --
IN THE MATERIAL SCIENCE AND
OTHER HARD SCIENCE FIELDS SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU WANT TO DEVELOP A
MEMBRANE THAT IS MUCH DOES A
MUCH BETTER JOB OF SEPARATING.
SALTS IN WATERS OF THE COMPUTER
FIREWATER OR YOU WANT TO DEVELOP
A NEW MATERIAL THAT WORKS AS A
BETTER LITHIUM ION BATTERY OR
SOMETHING THAT GOES BEYOND
LITHIUM ION.
THESE ARE HARD SCIENCE QUESTIONS
AND WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE AND
WORK WITH YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT
NOT ONLY DO IS DOES CALIFORNIA
DEVELOP AND RESEARCH THESE BUT
THAT AS WE THINK ABOUT
MANUFACTURING THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO THAT.
HERE IN THE STATE I WOULD ALSO
CALL OUT BIOSCIENCES --
THE CURRENT MODEL IN BIOSCIENCES
TAKE A MICROBE YOU FEED IT SUGAR
AND YOU GOT A CANCER CURE OR
LIKE ABBAS DINNER HERCEPTIN OR
YOU GET A NEW MATERIAL.
THE HARD CHALLENGE THAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH OF A BY A RESOURCES
ECONOMY SUMMIT WE CO HOSTED WITH
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD A FEW
WEEKS AGO.
IS HOW DO YOU TAKE FOREST'S
WASTE AGRICULTURAL WASTES AND
BREAK THOSE DOWN TURN THOSE INTO
FEED STOCKS THAT A MICROBE CAN
DIGESTING GIVE YOU AT NEW
CHEMICAL OR NEW PLASTIC OR
SOMETHING IT REPLACES A
PETROLEUM BASED.
OPPORTUNITIES SO WE THINK
THEY'RE MAJOR OPPORTUNITIES
THERE.
AND THEN I WOULD ALSO A
HIGHLIGHT WE HAVE BETWEEN
LAWRENCE LIVERMORE AND LAWRENCE
BERKELEY WE HAVE TWO OF THE TOP
TEN SUPERCOMPUTERS IN THE WORLD.
WE LEAD AND SHOULD HAVE CALLED --
ADVANCED COMPUTING FOR HIGH
PERFORMANCE MANUFACTURING AND
THE IDEA THERE IS TO ALLOW THE
COMPANIES THAT WANT TO MAKE
THEIR PROCESSES MORE ENERGY
EFFICIENT AND IF I AND AND COST
EFFECTIVE. TO GIVE THEM SOME
COMPUTER TIME TO RUN SIMULATIONS
THAT ALLOW THEM TO BECOME MORE
COMPETITIVE SO THAT'S JUST AN
EXAMPLE THE TOOLS.
WE LOVE WHAT WHERE YOU'RE GOING
AND WE LOVE TO BE A RESOURCE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHAT AT THIS TIME I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I HOPE YOU FOUND I
THIS HEARING TO BE A SOLID STEP?
IN DEVELOPING SOUND ECONOMIC
POLICIES THAT ENCOURAGE JOB
GROWTH I SUPPORT ENTREPRENEURS
AND SUPPORT OUR BUSINESS
COMMUNITY I WANT.
TO NOW THANK OUR PUBLIC --
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FOR
SPEAKING IN TESTIMONY TODAY AND
FOR OUR PANELISTS FOR JOINING US
I WILL NOW ADJOURN THIS MEETING